and uh looking forward to a good
executive session uh this morning and uh
it's not going to be be as heavy as we
thought we've decided to hold on a
couple of bills so we'll go from there
um I'd like to open the session on HB
542 relative to weekly benefits amounts
compensation you're actually you're
absolutely right would you like to lead
us
to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
roll
yes uh representative avalani
pres uh clerk present representative FL
here representative Prout representative
Warden good morning representative drgo
here representative Granger hi
representative farington here
representative Hall here representative
L here representative Sullivan here
representative Cahill here
representative D sylvestro here
representative Susi here representative
buard here representative McKenzie here
representative Schultz here
representative lir here representative
stop here chairman kraton here thank you
sir thank you representative kahill for
that reminder appreciate it now let's
open the the executive session on HB
542 on HP 542 uh we had decided last
week that there was more information
required and so we're gonna uh we recess
542 and we're going to reopen the
hearing next week at 10: a.m. this
closes the exec session on
5:42 I now like to open this the
442 HB 442 is relative to prohibiting
payment of sub subminimum wages
representative Warden uh do you have a
motion yes I move in expedient to
legislate
and representative Granger do you have a
second a
second and R Warren would you like to
speak to your motion yeah just briefly
we've heard testimony on both sides but
it hasn't been demonstrated this
actually needed almost nobody
is um making minimum wage anymore and
it's the system seems to work we like to
not insert ourselves any more in between
employers and employees than we have to
let them offer the compensation that
works that attracts employees in this
tough uh tough Market to find
employees let's not mess it
up and would you like to speak to your
second representative Granger yes Mr
chairman uh so I think it would hurt
Tipp workers and uh make it harder for
smalltime restaurants to thrive and uh
we already have a pretty excessive meals
and rooms tax and uh this leads to a
situation where our economy is dominated
most in the food sector is dominated by
chilies and Applebees and things like
that instead of uh small more Niche food
restaurants which we would like to have
Thrive therefore I oppose this all right
are there any other comments seeing
representative
Schultz thank you Mr chair first of all
I'd like to thank representative stab
and the committee I was sick for the
hearing on my bill and I she did a
wonderful job on on uh the Bill's behalf
and I appreciate that very much um
couple quick points um one of the best
things about this bill is 11 states have
already um put this into law
and we know from those States and they
um uh vary from uh Montana to California
to Washington State and uh I believe
Utah so it's not like they were all blue
States or red States it was a nice mix
of that and we know from that uh that
those states are doing well the
restaurants in those area are doing well
and it turns out when uh employees make
uh decent enough way wage they uh create
happy customers and thriving restaurants
so we know this by comparing the states
we also know that there have been a
number of Department of Labor violations
in New Hampshire from a number of
restaurants that have been determined to
not be paying their workers enough and
in fact have to pay these large fines
and pay the workers at a minimum the
minimum wage uh that is actually the law
that at the very least despite what the
tipped subminimum wage is in this state
is
$3.20 an hour then in fact uh all
employees need to make at a minimum the
minimum wage and those um cases have
been been pretty compelling that uh
those that are investigated and I'm sure
there are many that get away with it
unfortunately have had to uh address
this issue so we know that in fact uh
plenty of workers make low wages at the
subminimum or minimum wage and should be
paid that and so there should be no
difficulty to pay them at the base level
what other low agage workers make and
that is the subminimum wage at a minimum
and then tips would be on top um we also
know that one of the reasons why we
struggle to have workers in our
restaurants uh is because many jobs
along the border of our state they
realize they can make
uh more money at the neighboring states
maybe that's an argument that's better
for another the minimum wage bill but it
does um impact this as well if you work
in Vermont or Maine or um Massachusetts
in general your wages are better because
at a at the minimum they're going to be
paid the 13 15 an hour at the very at
the very least um I'm blanking on one of
my other points
when I remember it I if we are still
talking about it I will uh raise that
point at this time but um there are
plenty of good reasons that that we need
this bill and the free market is one of
them turns out uh you know uh one of the
things that isn't always taken care of
in the free market is that we choose
workers over for lack of a better word
greed if you have the ability to have
more money versus less money and you're
in control of the money turns out you're
going to take more money not everyone
does that we oh that is my other point
um uh Alex Ray who is the biggest
restaurant tour in New Hampshire he owns
the Common Man family of restaurants not
a Democrat or Republican very much an
independent he's been a part of the
movement to ditch the subminimum wage as
a concept um and then I'll throw in I I
I pretty sure you raised this point the
only reason why we have a sub minimum
wage in the first place is when uh
slavery ended it was a way to make
workers predominantly African-American
workers in um the hospitality industry
uh make them dependent on the uh
Goodwill of the customers so it's still
created a dependency that um still
exists to this day I mean we went from
zero wages at that time to $3.20 in this
in the time of 150 years so just at the
base level no other country on Earth has
it like this tipping culture is tipping
culture that's not what this bill is
addressing and that way tipping will
still happen so just at a base level to
have the minimum wage available to
workers and you know the free market can
account for that if an employer can't
pay at the base
$725 an hour maybe that's a restaurant
that doesn't need to stay open that is
the harsh reality of of a a free Market
but it's maybe the best thing I will say
we have great restaurants in the state
and great restaurant tours um but to do
so on the backs of workers at a sub rate
is just something that um should not be
the case and I hope we become the 12th
state to uh ditch the sub minimum wage
thank you thank you ma'am president K
um there's a tiny little restaurant in
my town of New Market and I've talk to
the owner and he pays his help $10 an
hour none of this subminimum weighing
and they get tips and and it works uh I
don't know why an industry that is very
successful it's our third largest uh
Revenue stream that the the8 and a half%
tax on it is the restaurant industry is
very successful why they can't afford to
pay the minimum wage at least and let
the chips flow as they are and belong to
the customer I know there's some
conversation in Washington about uh not
taxing tips anymore so you know if that
happens then this would even be better
you be able have your weight staff uh
not have a turnover in the restaurant uh
be able to afford to pay the rent and
maybe even for child care and you know
so they'd have a secure earnings of 725
an hour uh and then the tips which is
because they provide good service not
because they you know that's a job that
all the employer to take the take the
tips and use it to pay their wage we
don't do that with other Industries uh I
also want to point off for the benefit
of my colleague that our restaurant
industry unlike many other places uh
they get 3% of that tax they collect
from the customer you put the you put
the you pay the check and they send them
their uh the tax in every month but
first they take out 3% and that's about
12 or15 million a year other states
don't play that so so um you know I have
nothing against the restaurant industry
I I enjoy going to a restaurant from
time to time my $100 a year but um you
know this is something that we really
should evolve away from thank you Mr
chair thank you sir for your comments I
comments seeing no comments on HB 442 Mr
clerk can you call a rooll the motion on
the table is itl for HB
442 representative avalani yes
representative
Flanigan representative Prout yes
representative Warden yes representative
Drago yes representative Granger hi
representative Fairington yes
representative Hall
yes the clerk yes representative L yes
representative Sullivan no
Representative kahill no representative
D salvestro no representative Susi no
Representative bushard no representative
McKenzie no representative Schultz no
Representative lir no representative
stab no representative Katon
I the eyes have
it what's the vote 11 n the eyes have it
so motion is
itl uh 11 to9
uh is there a is the on the majority
report representative Warden you got
that yes
and represent Schultz
Schultz and again as always if we can
I'd like to open the hearing on HB 726
FN relative to State minimum wage and
Aller
rate and representative fton do you have
a motion to be made yes I move
inexpedient to legislate motions been
made inexpedient to legislate is there a
second I'll second representative Drago
for a second representative farington
can you speak to your motion yes sir I
believe that while the bill may be
well-intentioned the actual effects of
the bill would be harmful that the bill
for the people that the bill seeks to
benefit and it's important to know what
a minimum wage law does what it does is
it says it's illegal to employ somebody
who skills don't justify in this case a
wage of $15 an hour and wages have
meaning behind their value the the value
of a wage doesn't just fall from Heaven
there's a value behind the wage and
that's attributed to the value that the
worker produces a firm will not employ
an employee unless they can produce at
least the value of their wage and what
this bill would do is over the course of
time it would raise that to $15 an hour
and so a natural effect would be
unemployment for low-skilled
employees and representative Drago thank
you representative drgo Do you have a
comments to your
second NOP I think he did a good job
explaining it all right representative
stab thank you Mr chair um first I I
would like to thank my fellow committee
members for all their thoughtful
questions when I introduced this bill I
appreciate your interest and
attentiveness I I believe that it is p
time for New Hampshire to restore our
minimum wage law and to raise our
minimum wage to a level that is
competitive with surrounding states
wages have risen in the last few years
years because most of our Workforce
lives an hour or less away from a state
where they are guaranteed a minimum wage
of $14 and $15 an hour and we currently
have a worker shortage our current
default wage of $725 cents an hour sends
a message to our workers and workers who
are considering moving to to the state
that they are not valued we know that
there are 60,000 New Hampshire workers
who are making less than $15 an hour in
our state and that they tend to be
people who work in jobs that are
important to all Granite Staters child
care workers home health aids the people
who keep the grocery stores and
convenience stores open so you can get a
gallon of milk when you need it the
people who hand you your coffee at the
drive up window in the morning who do
more for us productivity in one shift
than most CEOs will do in their
lifetime and there are many others they
are vital to our economy and our quality
of life and they deserve a fair wage so
I will be voting against the itl motion
thank you thank you for your
comments representative
lir uh thank you Mr chair just one thing
I'd like to point out is that over the
years well I've only been on this
committee for this is my third year but
a couple of the bills that passed last
year kind of went with the with the cola
right with the cost of living and uh for
whatever reason this one
doesn't and I know it's it's it's
initially seems like a big jump from the
725 to I believe what the 10 or whatever
the next increment is but if we would
have maybe kept up a little bit over the
past 20 some odd years since it was
brought up to 725 it might not hurt so
much and again I know that people are
already making more so why not bring it
up I I understand the reasoning for not
bringing it up to some degree but uh it
just seems like for all the uh reasons
that representative stab said and I
don't disagree with the arguments either
necessarily but um even if we just
brought things up to with the cost of
living at least to some degree it would
help a lot of people thank you thank you
sir representative Granger thank you Mr
chair I got out of high school in 2008
and that was a high school dropout this
is Story Time with Granger and 2008 was
not a very good time to be entering the
job market and I remember having an
incredibly hard time finding a job
because I was competing with bank CEOs
for retail jobs that wasn't an easy
position to be in but I was living at
home and my expenses were incredibly low
and I would have killed for a job that
paid $2 an hour just so I could have
something on my resume but I could not
do that because new New York had at the
I lived in New York at the time suei uh
New York at the time had a minimum wage
law that prevented me from being able to
get any employment and we are not always
going to live in good
times and I feel I have a lot of empathy
for my colleague over here who's in a
younger generation than I am and there's
there's going to be some tough times
ahead and there's going to be kids
getting out of high school they're going
to be dropping out of high school like I
did who need a job and this will just be
an obstacle and as well-intentioned as
it is it hasn't always been well
intentioned that back in the past they
used to push minimum wages specifically
to prevent certain people from having
certain jobs and competing with other
people that was the historical intent
and honestly it did a pretty good job of
it at the time but uh I I don't want to
um belabor the point but I do not want
to inflict a minimum wage on the young
people there's already a sense among the
Zoomers Generation Z as they're called
that the economy is rigged against them
to favor the elderly at the expense of
the young and can you really blame them
considering all the things that they've
went through in their high school years
uh with the Corona virus lockdowns with
everything else that we've gone on with
the economy that it is I don't think
that previous generations intentionally
rigged the game against young people but
but the fact of the matter is a minimum
wage what it actually does is rig the
game against young people therefore I
fully and wholeheartedly support an itl
motion thank you thank you sir
representative bashard thank you Mr
chair uh just to add to representative
star's uh
testimony I I will not be able to
support the itl motion because we by
increasing the minimum wage we can lift
Working Families out of poverty and
strengthen our middle class class this
not only improves Financial stability
for
individuals but also eases the burden on
social support programs when workers
receive a wage that meets basic living
standards their Reliance on government
assistance diminishes this means fewer
resources are spent on public assistance
ultimately saving taxpayer dollars that
can be invested in other critical areas
in our community
additionally increasing the minimum wage
enhances worker productivity and
retention employees who feel valued are
more likely to be engaged and committed
leading to reduce turnover and improve
efficiencies this has a positive impact
on the overall quality of services
provided and the economic Vitality of
our state thank you Mr chair thank you I
appreciate it representative Schultz
thank you Mr chair and just want to say
that this topic in particular is one of
those that isn't not that isn't partisan
um it is actually a very mainstream view
to want a decent enough minimum wage and
this is true a majority of Republicans
in every District across the state
anytime we've pulled it in 2008 until
this year it is wildly popular and
that's because the rank and file voter
in this state regardless of of party
knows that we shouldn't have jobs that
don't pay you enough to afford the
basics they know because either people
in their family or themselves um the
majority of people earning low wages are
women often with kids uh in you know
from their 20s till their 50s and uh
what good is a job in New Hampshire if
you can't feed your kids pay the rent do
the basics we're not asking for some
Pathway to to wealth here we're just
asking that all jobs and I agree with uh
representative Fairington in this sense
the value of a wage should be equal to
the value of what it takes to live in
New Hampshire plain and simple the
modesty of a decent wage should be the
bare minimum of what we have uh and it
would be nice if employers all just did
this but um that's why we do what we do
thank
you thank representative McKenzie sir
you I think you can make a pretty good
argument that um and I've heard this in
the room before that nobody's being paid
the minimum wage in the state of New
Hampshire the 725 is a federal minimum
wage we decided a few years ago to
eliminate our minimum wage in the state
of New Hampshire so number one we don't
have one and we probably should but
secondly looking at the bottom
occupations in the state there is no
body making that I can see at least away
from the Department of Employment
Security people who are making 725 an
hour they're not making it so if there
was if the bill said we would pay $10 an
hour or $12 an hour would that make any
difference I don't think it would
because what this comes down to is the
employers want the opportunity to be
able to adjust wages up and down with
the economy and that's a that's a roller
coaster for for workers who are in this
economy trying to
survive now when you also when you look
at the low wage workers in the state the
people who would most benefit by a $15
an hour as my colleague said are those
they cluster in certain areas in child
care and in uh in uh food preparation
and weight staff and cashiers and people
like that who are at the low end and in
the in people who are in those
profession
who are servicing the state by the
thousands are not working one job
they're not working one job they're
working two jobs three jobs and that's
that's where we are in New Hampshire and
let me say every day a 100,000 people
leave the state of New Hampshire to go
to Massachusetts to
work is this one of the reasons why it's
a low minimum wage one of the reasons
why when they can just slip over the
border and make more money doing the
same job so from an economic perspective
does this make sense are we losing
people are we draining the the pond for
Massachusetts because of because of this
system and finally I would just say that
you're absolutely right it's not all
kids who are working for minimum wage
there are a lot of people in this
economy who are working for minimum wage
in fortunately at 725 or8 or N9 to $10
an hour and some of of them are
childcare workers and childcare workers
in this state are the most
neglected most valuable group of people
and the most neglected in our economy so
we need to deal with this in terms of
the broad economy uh and look at issues
like this and the impact that these are
having and a low minimum wage in the
state or no minimum wage in the state is
a is a component of our Economic
Development pece thank you Mr chairman
thank you for your
comments so I I
I just have a
personal Flanigan representative sir
over to you thank you Mr chairman just
as uh I don't know what you call it but
my daughter owns a
preschool and their their employees are
not paid minimum wage and if uh they
have a child they can go to the
preschool without any costs so not that
I want to correct representative
McKenzie I just want to clarify that not
all people in the childcare in industry
are paid even $15 I think she's in the
20s so
um just uh you know providing some
clarification thank
you uh thank you for the comment and I I
just wanted to make a quick comment so I
I worked for $13 an hour four years ago
and that's that's what we got paid at uh
at crotchett Mountain and as a result of
that the Mountain closed 40% of of its
operating hours it closed Mondays it
closed Tuesdays it closed all nights
except for Friday and Saturday night so
when you add it all up the hours it was
a 40% reduction in the operating time of
the mountain the reason was they
couldn't hire
anyone no one wanted to work for $13 an
hour except for Knuckleheads like me
who's
retired and so what they ended up doing
is they
increased their minimum wage from $113
to I believe it was 21 but it might have
been
20 and that was three years
ago uh when they had their hiring fair
in September for this
season there was minuscule openings and
that's because everyone came back and so
my point on the minimum wage is that the
market drove that and rather than people
leaving the state they came to
State because the the company recognized
that they were way out of line and now
we're doing great so I I understand uh
representative McKenzie's point but I my
experience a little bit different are
there any other
comments represent lry are you
suggesting sir the law of supply and
demand
worked I I didn't say that but that
would seem to apply okay thank you
representive
Solomon that that was a very good
example of uh how the market can work
and the market does work some of the
time um the minimum wage fills in when
the Market's not working and
um we will still have supply and demand
um employers paying what they need to to
get good employees and it is often well
above minimum wage even if the minimum
wage is $15 an hour um
but as has been pointed out there are
some lines of work um where the
employers um don't pay the 10 1215 an
hour and those are the folks that we're
trying to um uh address here thank you
okay thank you for those comments
represent brashard um thank you Mr chair
uh just to add on to
uh showing so sometimes the market
doesn't work well I I represent a very
diverse economically uh diverse ward in
the city of
Manchester and some of my constituents
tell me they need to work two or three
jobs just to make in meet and they laugh
at suggestions go to school the question
is where do I find time to do that so
there are a great am amounts of times
where the market doesn't
work thank you for that
comment okay seeing no further
comments uh Mr clerk can you call the
role the motion is itl on HB 726
FN representative avalani
yes clerk yes representative Flanigan
yes representative proud yes
representative Warden yes representative
drgo yes representative Granger hi
representative Fairington yes
representative Hall yes representative
lbre yes Representative selvan no
Representative
kahill
no representative D sylvestro no
representative Susie no Representative
buard no representative McKenzie
no representative Schultz no no
Representative lir no representative
stab no representative kraton
yton all right and representative
farington uh you've got the report okay
and for for your side
I closed the hearing on HB 726 and open
hearing on HB
744 on HB 744 U there was an additional
information that was being gathered and
collected and we agreed last week to
postpone uh to recess that hearing and
open it again uh next week so we'll
listen to that in the morning along with
HB 542 and so we will not exec uh HB 744
this
morning and I close the hearing on
7:44 I'd like to open the hearing now on
HB uh
378 relative to an employes unused uh
time and representative proud do you
have a motion thank you Mr chairman I
move in expedient to
legislate the motion on the table is in
inexpedient to legislate we have a war a
second and we have a second M
representative proud would you like to
speak to
your to your um motion yes thank you Mr
chairman um this bill would add
regulations to businesses requiring
strict accounting of leave uh it's not
clear how this would interact with
companies that have unlimited leave
policies um Massachusetts where I work
had did a similar policy for sick leave
a couple years ago uh the net result is
my company revoked its unlimited
untracked and no paperwork sick leave
and went to a strict accounting system
to the detriment of of everyone
involved uh this bill would turn uh the
the leave balance instantly into a
liability on the balance sheet of
companies potentially affecting their
credit uh additionally this bill uh has
kind of the vibe of an expost facto law
it's not limited to leave earned after
the effective date of the bill it would
actually affect leave earned before the
effective date of the bill as well uh
this sets up time up a time bomb for
companies that aren't paying attention
to changes in law if they've previously
had a large uh acrel allowed in their
policy
and while the proposed amendment limits
this to a month and a half of payout
that only limits the damage it really
doesn't change the nature of why it's a
bad idea um this bill would also make it
harder for uh business owners and as
experience has shown me potentially
worse for workers as well doe their
employers understandable reactions law
and so for these reasons I recommend
finding this bill in expedient to
legislate thank you for your comments
represent waren do you have a comments
represent K sir the floor is yours thank
you Mr chair um of course I have I do
have an amendment which i' I'd hope we
would take into consideration it cleaned
up a few of the things okay and I'm and
I'm I'm reminded of a conversation I had
maybe it was last term or the term
before when the gentleman uh Mr proud
told me that because he worked in
Massachusetts he had have benefited from
their law when uh something happened in
his vacation would have done would have
gone way he end up getting paid so it's
a
little uh you know do you like it when
it works for you it doesn't like it when
it might not work for you that's that's
that's a concern for me but uh I did I
did work hard in this amendment to uh
clean things up uh again it's only it
only takes effect Under The Limited
circumstances solely when there's a
layoff sale or closure of the business
and I understand that there was some
agreement uh among my Republican
colleagues that when it when a business
is sold or or or it closes they should
do the right thing and pay the uh uh the
unused vacation time uh but a layoff is
another occurrence that's beyond the
control of the employee unanticipated
and allows them no opportunity to use
that which they have earned I want to
make clear this is part of compensation
you earn it it's part of your it's part
of your pay and so under these limited
circumstances when this happened you
would get paid and and the law doesn't
take effect until January 1 plenty of
time for any employer to become aware of
it it doesn't require a massive overhaul
of any policy it just says uh that you
can't do this you can't keep that money
that the person earned whether it's $100
or $500 or $1,000 as the examples I've
shown you you can't keep it when when
they had no opportunity to take the time
because the actions of the employer
that's all it does it doesn't break it
doesn't break anybody's budget you you
when you have your policy to you're
going to have vacation time whatever way
you're doing it you assume that it's
going to be used and it should be used
but if it if you deny the person the
opportunity to use it you really should
pay them and that's that's really all I
have to say about it uh it would be nice
to defeat this uh itl and get get back
to an OTP
otpa uh and that would be the right
comments Mr clerk call
roll representative avalani
yes the clerk yes representative
Flanigan representative proud yes
representative Warden yes representative
Drago yes repres represenative Granger
yes representative Fairington yes
representative Hall yes representative
lbre yes representative Sullivan no
Representative kahill no representative
D sylvestro no representative Susi no
representative Bard no representative
McKenzie
no representative Schultz no
Representative lir no representative
stop no representative kraton
I 119
yay all right representative proud
you've got the uh committee report and I
assume representative kill you've got
you this closes the hearing on HB
378 I'd like to open the hearing on HB
375 and uh or correction 7:35 and I'd
like to uh we're going to hold this
until next week last hold and um
represent get another 150 and
representative grer owes beers for each
one of
those um but we're going to hold that
until next week and representative schz
request Bourbon please all right uh I
appreciate the patience on 7:35 thank
you very much and this closing the
hearing on
7:35 okay this closes the executive
session uh we will recess until 1100
hours when we'll start
e
to open the hearing on HB
38386 prohibiting nursing agencies from
including non compete Clauses in
contract with health care and
entities and uh representative priest uh
welcome good morning
everyone good morning everyone I'm David
priest I represent District 17 in
Hillsboro County and that's in Ward 2 in
Manchester and I have been approached by
some of my
constituents um who have been uh
directly
impacted by non-compete clauses in
contracts with nursing
agencies there are and that's why I am
supporting and I'm here today to support
HB
386 and this bill would prohibit nursing
agencies from including non compete
Clauses in
contracts with health care
agencies currently there's two laws
impacting nurses employment and
non-competes in New
27570 which requires employers to
notify employees of non-compete as a
condition of
employment and provide a copy to
potential
employees before an offer of
employment and second there is RSA
326b
45a which Vo void
restrictions to practice within a
geographic region in nurses
contracts nursing agencies bypass these
laws by placing non-compete articles in
their contracts with organizations that
provide Staffing
services this legislation is intended to
close that
loophole that nurses agencies especially
those based outside of New Hampshire are
exploiting at expense of
public the nurses are unaware that they
are under a non-compete clauses in their
contracts nurses working for an agency
are commonly assigned to multiple organ
organizations this creates a network of
organizations that nurses cannot work
for at for a specific period ENT
trapping them with the
agencies for a nurse to be able to leave
the agency and work at an organization
they were previously assigned to the
organization needs to compensate the
agency especially
and and this is
essentially purchasing the person from
the
agency traditional Health Care
organizations are not the only
facilities that require nursing staff
other
organizations including schools Child
Care Facilities correctional facilities
and occupational health have nursing
positions that require Staffing and have
used
agencies providing financial
compensation to the agency in exchange
for the nurse can cost tens of thousands
of dollars per nurse in addition to the
highly hourly wage that the agency
charges than direct
hires this increase in health care
expenditure
eventually gets passed along to the
public through increases in Medicare and
Medicaid taxes and out of-pocket health
care
cost to summarize many nursing agency
bypass the two statutes in the New
Hampshire law by placing non-compete
clauses in their contracts with
organizations and holding organizations
financially liable instead of
individuals and not informing the nurses
that they
employ nurses are prohibited from
leaving the agencies to work for the
organizations they were assigned with
for a specific period of time entrapping
them when assigned to multiple
organizations unless the organization is
willing to pay the agency a substantial
amount of money to puras to purchase the
nurse from
them not only are traditional Health
Care Facilities impacted increasing
General Health care
costs but also Public Schools County
State and correctional facilities are
also impacted resulting in agencies
profiting from the
taxpayers behind me are several nurses
that have been impacted by this and if
you have questions
regarding what has happened to them they
will be testifying later on so in
summary I urge you to pass HB 386 and I
have a letter to give to you after some
questions thank you representive
solivan thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
um all of us are um delegates for our um
counties and um all of us are involved
with uh County nursing homes um can you
tell us what impact um these um uh
non-compete clauses have had on our
County nursing
homes the one that I'm familiar with is
hillsb girl nursing home and they have a
shortage of nurses and so they staff
them with nurses from nursing
agencies and so what happens if like for
Bedford um nursing home a Hillsboro
nursing home um they like the nurse she
likes them they want to have a marriage
between them but she can't leave the
agency and the county cannot afford the
thousands of dollars that is offered to
buy her from the
agency so they're left in a very
impacted area followup for followup
sir my understanding is the agency
nurses um cost the county a lot more
than a um nurse on staff that's
correct and um there for would I be
correct in thinking that um these um uh
non-com compete Clauses cost the
counties our County
taxpayers a lot of money as well that's
correct thank
you thank you good question
representative Granger uh thank you Mr
chair so is it am I correct in
understanding that the general premise
of this bill is to increase the
liquidity in the in the nurse labor
market that's correct so in if that were
the case can I do a follow-up
for followup uh would would you mind if
it was only applied to organizations
that accept public funds or Medicaid or
things like that I'm I I I can't answer
that right now maybe the people behind
me are able to do that thank you
represent Prout uh thank you um would
this only apply to someone changing jobs
or um or would a non-compete clause for
simultaneous employment still be allowed
so that they can't like Moonlight
somewhere else for example would that
prohibition still be allowed on my
understanding is if they've signed with
an agency they're with the agency and
they cannot work outside of their
contract and their the network of
organizations that the agency has
contracted
with I don't know if that's kind of
indirect but y I don't think they can I
I don't think they can Moonlight for a
followup yep so but does this bill
address only the their trying to change
employer situation or does it also
prohibit or or make it so that they
can't have a Moonlighting Prohibition in
the
contract I I I think that they cannot
leave the agency itself so it prohibits
them from seeking employment outside of
their agency thank you okay
representative kill thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative priest for
taking my question um in the
conventional uh temporary employment
Market Market they often have temped
perm where if the employee Works 6
months uh as as a signed by the agency
they can be car they can be hired a
direct hire is this anything that
happens in the nursing uh agencies um I
can't answer that question but there's
people behind me that are are able to do
thank
you repres
Flanigan thank you Mr chairman um I if I
understand this correctly these nursing
um agencies yeah are similar to pardon
me head hunters for the nursing industry
in other words versus in regular um job
field you know you go the people solicit
work for you you go there on a temporary
basis but in those
instances for no other words you do
belong to the Head Hunter in other words
you got the contact and you got the work
through them so what you're saying to me
in this regards and correcting if I'm
wrong is that uh so if you're a nurse
and these people have jobs for
you um you can't go around the agency
and you'd like to be able to go around
the agency that's correct that's correct
if you want let's say let's say a
nurse is hired by or is hired by the
agency she signs the contract they
assign her to a particular Health Care
Facility the health care facility
through a direct hire would give her a
higher salary and probably better
benefits but she can't leave the agency
because she's because of the no compete
clause in her contract followup for a
followup yes sir thank you Mr chairman
so so basically as you have an agreement
between two parties and you don't like
the agreement and what you want to do is
I us create a law that says you can
break the agreement that says you belong
to them because they found you the job
they help you out with benefits or
whatever the case may be based on those
contracts and you your your constituents
don't like that meaning the nurses they
want to go out on their own or they want
to get a full-time job at the company
that they're temping at well I think
it's I think it's broader than that the
cost of this is costing the taxpayers
the the nursing facilities much more
because the agencies are charging a much
higher rate for the nurses I get it and
the nurses are being compensated at a
much lower rate than they would be if
they were out on their own I I think
it's a I think it's an issue of not
knowing what is in their
contracts and
basically um signing an agreement that
are not familiar not being told the
particulars of their contract at the
beginning so representative
Alani thank you Mr chairman you stated
that they sign their contract before
they start work do they not read the
contract before start they start
work I I I can't answer that for the
nurses represent D sylvestro and then
representative Sullivan thank you sir
thank you for taking my question it
sounds as though once they get into the
ageny it's a way that they know they can
get a job they're out of state they come
to New Hampshire to to obtain a job and
then once they hear as you I think you
said earlier the employer likes them
they want to work here so it's really a
question um it takes their Liberty and
their choices away in order to try to
improve themselves by getting a
permanent job and then helps us in the
state to lower our costs through our
County that's
correct
Sol just to
clarify it uh I believe you you
testified earlier that the non-complete
Clause is not in a um uh contract
between the nurse and the um agency or
the nurse and the um the facility but
it's between the agency and the facility
so the nurse doesn't sign it the nurse
doesn't read it is that correct that's
correct thank
you okay I'm sorry just to clarify and
I've got you but I'm that's a great
question so I'm I ask it a different way
because so I'm a nurse I go to the
agency I sign a contract with the agency
is there a non-compete clause in that
agency you know I'm confused myself
right now between the agency and the
organization the nurses it's not in the
nurses
contract okay okay good thank you for
asking so that's a big thing
okay representative Granger and then
I've got a couple on this side I've got
you tracking but representative Granger
you're next oh thank you Mr chair so so
would this be retroactive so for
instance if there's already a contract
signed of this nature would that be
invalidated by this I believe so thank
you and representative stop thank you Mr
chair um typically how long are are
these contracts between the nurses and
the agencies for is it a year six months
I I can't answer but there's people
behind me they can okay thank you thank
you and are there any questions did I
miss someone represent
McKenzie uh thank you for coming in
front of US Representative and uh the
question I have is how does this impact
the temp agencies in general is this
does this just C the nursing out of that
because it's the practice in for temp
workers in temporary agencies is
generally this you you hire a temp and
then if you want want the temp you buy
buy the temp out from the uh from the
agency and I you know we used to do that
um you get a chance to see the person
see how they work and then and then the
agency uh will give you a price in terms
of that so does this affect that at all
and the other thing I I you could
profile let let's do one at a
time sorry one question at a time well
that my curious about how this impacts
the rest of the uh the if it involves
with the temp AG gencies as well if it's
just a carve out okay I I believe it's
just a carveout addressing this
you Library thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question uh so I'm the
one of the business owners in the bunch
here and one of my questions is um how
does this affect the agency you know
down the road if all the nurses were to
to jump ship if you would um and and
left the agency and just went direct to
work for the facility
what would happen then to the agency
would they go out of business or what I
don't think they would go out of
business but I don't think they would be
getting the profits that they have in
the past okay follow up please so if
they weren't getting the profits that
they had previously would they then
maybe be not interested in continuing
I'm just trying to trying to make sure
everybody's protected I can't answer
that question cuz I'm not I don't know
the ageny thank you representative
Granger
thank you Mr chair is this intended
specifically is is it designed with the
temp agencies in mind primarily like the
nursing agencies
or just for the nurses agencies just the
nurses agencies right okay represent
waren thank
you question is a basic business
question whether it's the County nursing
home or another medical provider
facility you I think you believe I
believe you stated that they they these
SE hiring a these hiring hospitals or
nursing facilities actually pay more for
a nurse through the uh agency than they
would if they hired that person directly
why is it why would these employers pay
more than they have to you explain that
from a business from a business
standpoint because they can't find
anybody around that's the
reason followup followup sir is it also
possible that some of these employers
prefer uh that type of arrangement
because it's easier for those people
it's easier to fire those people if
they're needs um are reduced for staff
for example it's easier to let a
contractor go than it is to let go an
employee is that I can't answer that for
the organizations but it doesn't just
affect Health Care it affects Public
Schools Correctional Facilities anything
so
problem um thank you I think I
understand the problem statement is that
essentially these these nursing staff
agencies are including these causes in
the contract with I I guess the the
problem could be restated as excessive
buyout fees that basically make it
impractical to actually execute that
clause for most organizations um and I
agree that that there's a that sounds
like a problem there especially as
relates to um the County nursing homes
and such but I and a little bit to um uh
my colleague's question there is I can't
imagine that the nursing agencies won't
react to this if they if we prohibit
this Clause they'll change the structure
of the contract in some other way
they're going to make their money
somehow do we have any idea of what
they're going to do instead are they
going to increase the base rate are they
going to try some other Clause I mean
I'm worried about the secondary effects
if we pass this do you have any
information on that well I I I don't
have the information on that but I did
have
correspondence um and I don't believe I
brought her with me and I'll be happy to
share that with you that there has been
a new
rule that has been
pregated um here it is and I'll leave
this with
you I mean this is just not a New
Hampshire problem this is this is a
National problem with these
agencies um and this this is with the uh
Federal Trade Commission and they were
uh communicating to
me that um the FTC was kind of banding
non-compete clauses and this rule hasn't
got into effect yet but it's on the
docket to be in effect okay followup for
a followup do you know if that rule
that's under contemplation would apply
to this situation because this isn't a
standard non-compete situation because
it is the contract between the agency
and the health care facility not a
standard non-compete that would be
between the agency and EMP I can't
answer that but there's others that
might be able okay representative
Granger thank you thank you Mr chair do
you happen to know what percentage of
nurses are hired through an agency I do
not have that
sir thank you for asking answering
question you and thank you for putting
up with me and there's again more
knowledgeable people who have been
directly impacted by this sitting behind
me so thank you again all right thank
Peterson if you could introduce yourself
sir and then uh where you're from that
would be great yes um my name is Rick
Peterson well it's okay just not wait
to Yes uh my name is Rick
Peterson I have been Associated and an
owner of Interim HealthCare a
supplemental Staffing Agency for 47
years I think we're the definition of a
family business here in New Hampshire
we're a licensed Home Health agency we
provide Staffing also to hospitals
nursing homes and schools and we've been
recognized by CMS as a Five Star Agency
which is the highest rating for Quality
that you can
get HB 386 as proposed is mostly
fine one section however is grossly
unfair a facility who we staff who
chooses to hire our employee when I say
our employee it's not ownership but an
employee that we sent
them uh just free and clear after we
have spent really thousands of dollars
through indeed and other hiring uh
uh software programs we've recruited
we've interviewed we've done reference
checking we've done drug testing
criminal background checking orientation
a skills review and finally we placed
that person and just to clear up the uh
sponsor we do not have a contract with
the
nurse the
legislation only covers staffing
agencies for nurses and nurses
AIDS those agencies providing technical
legal clerical or light industrial are
not
included seems to me this legislation
uh
we look at this a little bit differently
and con consider this and this is as
crazy as it sounds but facilities should
be opposed to this
legislation and the reason I say opposed
and I think one of the representatives
over here said well what's going to
occur if if uh we do pass this
legislation and I can tell you
potentially what can occur if we go to
that expense and we staff a facility and
the first time in they I guess the word
could be poach the
employee we're not going to staff them
we've spent thousands of dollars hiring
that person and we're not going to
provide that care again and again and
again and have people that we've spent a
lot of money for
leave that is going to increase costs
and
interesting and again after 47 years of
experience in this the facilities call
us when they've exhausted their
opportunities
internally and it may have been through
the the flu that went through the
building and they need some prum staff
it may be I mean we co the state of New
Hampshire provided a uh funding to
Interim HealthCare particularly to go in
and staff facilities that uh were on
their literally on their knees because
their staff had had
dissipated and the patients they didn't
want to close the
facility the Staffing shortages for
nurses is not going to be solved by
creating an environment of conflict and
and instead of a an environment of a
collaborative effort this is just first
class conflict and the patients are in
danger of not getting care when we're
called the facility has exhausted all of
their alternatives
and and they've offered overtime to
their existing staff they've combed
their their uh people that have left and
call those emergencies occur and they're
hard to plan for and that's where the
supplemental agency like ours comes into
play we
don't the the sponsor of the
bill I think might be a little bit
misinformed if we're sending somebody
into a to a
facility we we build a relationship I
mean we've been I've been doing this
since the ramir and the mccurley's
families these were family nursing homes
and we we establish a long-term
relationship with our customers as any
good business would do
and
we we provide that care because they
really need somebody and where they to
provide
it the other thing about about agencies
is we contribute to the supply of
nurses and when I say nurses I'm talking
about nurses and nurses AIDS which as
you probably know are in very short
supply and the reason we contribute to
the supply is we give the alternative
some for people who want to work one day
a week or two days a week or three days
a week and their schedule varies they
can't take a full full-time job and so
the role of the supplemental nursing
service is really important to providing
that
care people need some flexibility from
time to time in their schedule and a
supplemental agency provides that so
there's there's some real downside in
passing this bill for the facilities and
I I'm not sure that they understand the
steps that agencies like ours would take
we wouldn't we would never continue to
send nurses in to a facility that is
picking off our people one by one by one
and then finally I'll just say if
somebody comes to us we don't own them
they can work anywhere they want but if
we've sent them to a facility we have a
13-week buyout and and uh they can work
if they're working two days a week and
they want to go to that facility and
they like it and they work for we figure
the hours out and it's a negotiated
settlement but we don't own anybody and
we can't control an employee from
working at another facility I mean
that's just doesn't work that way the
it's that's a it just doesn't work um
they can work where they want the only
restriction is where we've just placed
them so um and and truthfully most
facilities will work with an agency to
if they want to hire somebody
to make that happen and we're all for
that we're not against it um but it but
it needs to be something called
liquidated damages if we're just getting
picked off one by one by one so I would
ask you to really take a hard look at
this bill and and urge you to uh on
sections EF which specifically relate to
that component and there as I mentioned
there are other components of the bill
which are fine it's just good business
it's ethical business business and and
that's the way a business relationship
should be so thank you very much and I'm
happy to answer any questions all right
thank you for your testimony represent K
you Mr chair and thank you Mr Peterson
for taking my question you just
mentioned a 13 we buyout is that a a
standard period that you use so that
after the person has worked 13 weeks
there's an amount at which or they you
they've done enough to recover your cost
yeah and and actually that's that's
negotiated a bigger customer that we've
had a long-term relationship with that's
a that's a negotiated settlement we as I
said we've been doing this for 47 years
and we pretty much have a nice
relationship with the customers for that
for that length of time so we we work
with people followup for followup thank
you sir um so are most of your nurses
from within the New England area or from
further away there people that you
recruit and and bring to New Hampshire
we're a local New Hampshire company we
have uh uh two offices in Maine but the
nurses are are our neighbors pretty much
thank you and they it's folks that just
want to pick up some extra
time and we provide that we cover them
with workers comp we cover them with
malpractice and liability when the
facility goes to to uh bring them in
through US they've been fully vetted
with criminal background and and and uh
reference checking and skills testing
and so forth which I had mentioned
previously
res uh thank you um one of the things
that I I heard in the earlier testimony
on this bill that kind of struck me as
as it potentially something that uh
should be an issue and I want to ask
whether it would be an issue for your
business is the fact that the nurses
don't know about these bio Clauses and
non-compete clauses in the contract
between the agency and the healthcare
facility um would it affect your
business much if there was a disclosure
requirement that the nurses that fill
the Staffing roles need to be told about
any Clauses of that nature any
restrictions on them jumping ship that
are enforced from the facility side that
appears currently there's no way that
they necessarily would be told under
existing processes well we cover that in
orientation with each which prospective
employee but if uh if there was some
signature require ired I mean I see that
as being acceptable it's not not trying
to hide anything we we just really want
to avoid going to the expense of hiring
somebody I mean indeed I think runs
about $3,000 a month for us uh that's
just one Avenue we use a lot thank you
represent
Drago thank you Mr chair I'm curious do
you try to keep the same nurses going to
the same clinic or do they go to all
different clinics when they work they
can but we try if they're happy there
and the facility is Happy there's I mean
it just set it and forget it basically
that's uh kind of a slanging way of
putting it I guess but if everybody's
happy there's no point in introducing
somebody new for followup sir so on
average how each one of your nurses how
many clinics would you say they they
work at or is it usually typically one
or two just one or two pretty much I
mean it depends how long they've been
with us some if they've been with us for
a long time they may work in a number of
facilities but we we try and limit it uh
because they're happy and the facility
is happy and they're comfortable in in
their job and the job uh requirements at
that particular facility one one more go
ahead so if you if you just hear the
bill it sounds like once they work for
somebody like you they they can't work
anywhere but would you agree that
generally speaking it's just a few
places that they can't work but when we
hire somebody they're not under under a
contract with just Interim HealthCare
they may work for two or three staffing
agencies and they're going to different
facilities and if they went to the same
facility
through through
us but it was a different supplemental
agency that's the way it goes
all right representative
McKenzie I got you thank you Mr chairman
uh so the it seems that you've had some
success in recruiting
people that uh and I'm coming from the
Hillsboro County delegation that we may
not have had uh the ability to recruit
the people that that so you're so you're
doing something to staff these
facilities that have not not figured out
at this point so what's the difference
what is it
that as a staffing agency and maybe it's
a little off track and if it is I'll do
this off offline but I I think it's
interesting that you're able to staff
these things we can't we have an
expression in the office is what you pay
attention to grows and we put our Focus
I mean we have recruiters and that's
what they do is recruit and we we have
uh artificial intelligence that that
places ads for us it's a prettyy
sophisticated process and and we put a
lot of energy and dollars into
that
uh and just to clear something up we
don't we don't pay any health benefits
these are these are per DM staff they
can work when they want to work they
tell us when they're
available so we we pay attention to the
recruiting that's what we do we put a
lot of effort into it uh as I said I
think we a lot of times we drop people
off the couch that because we just uh we
go back in in the uh nursing licenses
and send out notices there that we have
work available we put a lot of effort
into
that and did you have a followup I I did
please so you don't pay uh you don't pay
health care for the employees there's no
benefits necessarily that you pay
vacation or any of that kind of stuff so
thank you and representative
Flanigan thank you Mr chairman and
thanks for taking our
questions I I see a uh similarity
between what you do and again I use the
word Head Hunter please accept my
apologies if it offends you but
basically you're finding bodies for jobs
that are open that an employer can't
find and my question of you is the
buyout provision if I could use that
term that's common in your in your
business is it not that if someone likes
the person we want them full time we
realize you've gone the effort of
finding this person for us and we're
willing to pay and it's agreed between
the parties right exactly and and not
not
unlike Kelly girl or Manpower or one of
the staffing agencies for light
industrial or clerical support staff
we're we're the same follow what for
followup yes so so someone had made a
comment about how if we pass this bill
that we could save all sorts of money at
the county level but the reality is is
the county couldn't do what you do in
other words they haven't been able to
find the worker to fill the job some
counties have I mean it it varies all
over what happens sometimes in a in a
facility is maybe they've hired somebody
that didn't didn't work out didn't work
out but there were Direct of healthcare
services and they have a walk out well
we get a call from that and it takes a
while for the facility to rebuild itself
and that's where that's where we step in
and then when it's when they've staffed
it and they we get a phone call and say
we're all set and that's that's it it's
a week to week deal mostly or even dayt
day followup Mr last one the last one um
your words yeah it is my words um so the
reality of the situation you go to all
this effort to find the staff you bring
the staff in because they can't find
them or it's it's a it's a a situation
where it's needed right away okay and
you have a provision in the agreement
with the party that you contract with
that says if they want that person they
have to pay for it because you've done
all this work ahead of time that they
either can't do or don't
Doh so basically this is interrupting
your whole income stream if they do
decide to take business model yeah and
and I would say that
which I think I mentioned earlier when
when we have longstanding customers and
we have a business relationship
absolutely we we work out those times
and we're not trying to step in
somebody's way our a nurse that works
for us we think about this if their if
their uh husband is a just use an
example a fireman and his schedule is
all over the place and she's a nurse and
they've got a couple of kids
if if something changes in their work
life um we're not standing in her way to
take a full-time job with benefits I
mean that would be that would really be
hurtful to our companies thank you R
Granger thank you Mr chair do you have
any idea the percentage of nurses that
are hired through agencies versus direct
I'm
sorry I'm not sure I understand the
question so some nurses are hired
through like an agency like your
organization and then some are hired
directly by the hospital or healthcare
provider right oh we have a very small
percentage of of of that I don't know I
couldn't put a number on it but but but
most nurses are direct then yes okay
thank you yes represent
San I mean there are facilities that we
do not staff and haven't staffed in in
years it's all their staff and others as
I mentioned earlier they may have a
outbreak of flu or they have a walk out
or somebody gets hurt and they call us
and say look we've got to we've got to
fill this we have patients that need
their meds we have any number of
things thank you sir U you've made it
very clear that um you don't want to
stand in the way of people working where
they want to work
um however you've made it very clear
that um if they want to work in the
facility that they're presently working
at through you it's going to cost the
facility something um can you go into
more detail as to Ju Just how much it's
going to cost the I mean
I'm sure for for my um Sullivan County
nursing home is you know what my
delegation supports and we are
continually hearing that the U the cost
of agency nurses is killing them um and
so um what would it cost Sullivan County
nursing home to um buy out one of those
uh nurses that's provided by an agency
the way we work it is let's say for
example we're we're we are uh Staffing
two days a week with a particular
nurse and we would say the
suggested in most cases for the next 13
weeks they would continue their working
two days a week and then they would be
on their own and if they went to five
days a week we would only charge them
the two days a week for the 13
weeks follow up please just just trying
to be clear so essentially the um the
nursing home would continue to pay the
agency two days a week at the agency um
rate right the other three days there
would be um a uh Sullivan County Nursing
Home employee and they could um but they
could start getting benefits and that
type of thing and then we have a
situation where they'll say look we just
want to bring this person on what would
it
cost we don't want to go 13 weeks and
and uh I can't give you a number because
sometimes that happens with nurses AIDS
sometimes it happens with nurses uh
those are or LPNs RNs so there's
different different rates on on those
employees but we would we would work out
a negotiate a settlement which parties
would agree to we want to continue to
have a customer and we would Contin I
mean nurses move and leave the facility
ities and that we we'd like to have a
nice business relationship where they
call back and after 48 years I think
we've done that represent
stop thank you um when someone signs up
with your um agency what is um the
required duration for example do do they
sign a one-year agreement with you or a
six-month agreement with
you they they can sign up and then never
work
okay we don't have a contract with the
nurse and they they they may go to two
facilities or one facility and don't
like it and say gez I this isn't working
out for me I don't like walking into a
strange Place may ask a followup yes
ma'am so when someone when you on board
somebody there isn't something that they
sign to say that they are they're in
agreement with the conditions of their
employment no okay thank you
sylvestro thank you and thank you for
taking my question so we covered a lot
of things and but the bill is actually
about non-compete so can you tell me
where that fits into your line if the if
they're working at Sullivan County I
represent Hillsboro County you're saying
that person can leave Sullivan County
and go work at Hillsboro County where's
the non canete come in as I understand
Bill is I understand the bill that I
mean the nurse can can leave us and go
to any facility as long as it's not it's
not the where we where we've been
Staffing her within a two-month period
of time or a month period of time we
don't want our staff walking into a
facility and having a hoorde of of the
first day in being brought down to HR
and T tried to sign them up and you know
we Hadar that all the time when they
come back sometimes that uh that's what
happened but if we if we were at
Hillsboro County sending a nurse in and
the nurse Mo moved to Sullivan County
they can go to work they could go to
work at Maple Lea nursing home I mean it
it's we can't hold
somebody's handcuff
somebody represent thank you for follow
no representative King
thank you Mr chair so I'm hearing a lot
of things about when an employee would
leave let's say somebody that comes to
you and wants employment and works
through your agency if that employee
were to voluntarily leave would they be
able to take a job for that not
specifically that organization but an
affiliate of that organization so like
let's say that organization owns several
facilities would they be able to work at
a different facility yeah I wouldn't see
any issue with that okay it's where we
staff the person that they they've
called us the facility has called us
we've we' we've bent over Backwoods so
to speak to to to put things in place to
send a qualified person that would that
we skill match him to go into that
facility and we would uh obviously not
want them hired after day two on a
permanent basis if they didn't didn't
like it and they went somewhere else
that's that's up to them and that
happens it happens
frequently k Mr chair and thank you
again Mr Peterson it sounds like you
know as you said you're a local company
in business for a long time have
relationships with the you know with the
with the nurses and with the
institutions can you just give me an
idea of how many other entities other
agencies are operating from out of state
that are probably using a different uh
method I I don't really know that I you
know
we we have agencies that come in go and
uh almost app an app app Staffing I
guess is is one but the facilities are a
fairly significant risk doing that I
mean somebody just signs up for an app
on an app and then goes to a facility
and that's why you know I'm not opposed
to all the aspects of a staffing bill um
I think it's important to have somebody
that is trained knows what they're doing
has a a
license uh has been vetted the criminal
background check which is a law it it
goes through the proper proper steps to
make sure somebody has been vetted and
qualified to step in to care for people
in a home or a hospital or a nursing
home or a hospital or a school thanks
stop I was gonna ask the same question
thank you
represent Clair thank you um so kudos to
your company when you send people to
someplace and they want to hire that
person obviously you've done a good job
and I it's well appreciated have you
ever tried to recruit someone that's
already working somewhere
local we we would not go into a facility
and recruit their staff right and and
again if you're looking to build a
business relationship that would end
that relationship and a heartbeat I mean
if we put an ad in the paper or look up
on
indeed uh and they come to you and they
come to us that's that's really a
different deal thank all right sir thank
you for your detailed testimony
appreciate it thank you thank and I'd
good morning chairman and members of the
committee my name is Patricia angland
I'm a school nurse in Manchester and the
union representative for the Manchester
School nurses I previously worked for a
Nur nursing agency for seven years
before finding a way out I witnessed
daily what these n what these
non-competes and bio Clauses due to
nurses organizations and taxpayers I'm
here to testify in support of Bill 386
um I'm actually the one that wrote the
wording for it and representative priest
was kind enough to submit it for me um
as he stated RSA 27570 requires
employers to notify employees of a
non-compete um in their contract as a
condition of employment prior to hiring
and submitting a copy to them prior to
hiring and then RSA 326b 45a voids
restrictions on nurses based on
geographic location many agencies are
subverting these laws by placing the
non-competes between the agencies and
the
organizations unfortunately it's taking
advantage of the nurses the healthare
system and the taxpayers I've been able
to confirm that the following agencies
have utilized this practice within the
past year Max them bed could you get a
little bit closer to Mike so we can hear
you back here thank you I've been able
to confirm that the following agencies
have utilized this practice within the
past year Maxum based out of Columbia
Maryland Procare based out of Denver
Colorado acor based out of piscatqua New
Jersey Bright Star based out of gurnie
Illinois Regency Home Health based out
of lonary New Hampshire Norton based out
of Cohasset Massachusetts and career
staff based out of Irving Texas um which
actually goes a step further and bans
the hiring of Staff even if they switch
to another agency most of these unlike
Mr Peterson's agency are one to twoe not
week New Hampshire's already
experiencing a nursing shortage
resulting in high competition and
increased labor costs nursing agencies
utiliz non-competes are taking advantage
of the shortage by preventing nurses
from freely moving to areas of need and
charging premium rates increasing
organizational
expenditures agency nurses are often
assigned to multiple organizations when
I was an agency nurse I did have a
couple regular organizations that I went
to however if there was a call out here
a call out there it was not unheard of
for me to be sent to many Al
organizations for a single day then
preventing me from working for those
places for one to two years without a
buyout it creates a network of
organizations where nurses cannot work
and trapping them for nurse to be able
to leave that agency and work at an
organization where they were previously
assigned that organization required to
provide compensation to the to the
agency essentially buying them according
to the New Hampshire Hospital
Association Hospital costs related to
contracted labor increased from 118.5
million in 2019 to 302.7 million in 202
22 with
133.5 increase from 2021 to 2022 alone
lastly hospitals are not the only
organizations requiring nursing staff
organizations and Facilities such as
Community Mental Health Centers
correctional facilities and public
schools funded by taxpayer dollars are
also required nursing staff any costs
associated with nursing agency
non-competes are passed directly to the
taxpayers through local taxes or
Medicare or Medicaid to put this in
perspective in Manchester School
District District we have 19 direct
hires we have 44
contracted for the Manchester School
District to buy out just half of those
is between $100,000 and $400,000 of
taxpayer money in conclusion I want to
make it clear I'm not against nursing
agencies they fill a need in the
healthcare Market I am against agencies
taking advantage of this need by
charging organizations exorbitant
amounts for their services and requiring
additional compensation for nurses to
leave the agency to work for those same
organizations if they choose this
control over nurses utilizing human
beings as a commodity to be purchased
for an agency's Financial benefit
directly opposes our free market
economic system there's no reason
agencies cannot utilize mechanisms
similar to other businesses such as
incentives and benefits to keep staff
rather than entrapping them to be
purchased as he was stating about
advertising he stated that he puts a lot
of money into advertising AI recruitment
staff all that that's just money that
public schools Corrections they don't
have that money so they're trying to
compete recruiting with an agency that
puts thousands of dollars into
advertising you go on indeed looking at
school nurse in Manchester Regency is
the first one that pops up because they
pay to be at the
top thank
you thank you for your testimony and can
you provide that
testimony uh to us yeah absolutely
please thank you and representative
proud thank you Mr chairman um so I
think we've already um kind of
identified that the hiding the clause in
the contract that the the employee
doesn't see uh is a problem do you see
that happening uh in the contracts that
uh you see in Manchester School District
yes we've actually had multiple nurses
who were agency who wanted to come over
because they wanted the stability of
even though we have lower pay they
wanted that stability of knowing that
were going to have work compared to
agency and there was no non-compete and
they kept searching there's like there's
no non-compete in my contract um many of
them were out of state agencies that
they were employed with however there
was that non-compete between the
organization and the agency and they had
no knowledge of that followup for
followup um do you have any insight into
why U Manchester School dist or any
other organization is accepting these
contracts I mean in instead of just
phoning up the agency of the previous
speaker that has more reason more 13we
terms or something um is it is it just
bad negotiating is it that they're
desperate and nobody else is filling the
position wh why why is this being signed
in the first place if it's turned into
such a problem hourly cost um so it goes
out for RFP and they look at the hourly
cost and what it's going to cost to fill
those positions if they can't direct
higher um and so obviously being a
public school tends to go to the lowest
cost to save the taxpayers money thank
you represent
Flanigan thank you Mr chairman and
thanks for coming in to testify my
mother was a
nurse
um I was reading the bill and it talks
specifically about the uh Health Care
Facility and the agency and so forth but
what happens if and I can't remember the
gentleman's name rck Rick Rick had an
agreement with Manchester School
District that Manchester School District
put in the language that if they wanted
to buy you out say you were the nurse in
question that they decided how much they
were going to pay in other words it
wasn't from Rick it was from the
ultimate contractor the the the school
district it wouldn't be in this bill the
law wouldn't apply because the way the
scenario worked out it doesn't match
what this was trying to do do you follow
what I'm saying I do I can't imagine an
organization would sit there and say I'm
going to pay x amount of dollars if they
don't have to follow for followup sir um
no what I'm saying is if if Rick was
providing 44 nurses to the Manchester
school and I hope you are um then the
school district would have a little bit
of authority in that negotiation in
other words he'd say okay if some of
these people work out we're going to pay
a flat $5,000 or something like that to
get them on our staff so this is where
the free market comes in agencies
traditionally pay significantly more
than the public sector so it becomes um
um a positive negative imbalance an
imbalance not an imbalance it's a
positive negative that each nurse would
have to weigh like do I want the higher
pay or do I want the stability and we
kind of see it go both ways um there's
many nurses that want to stay with the
agency they want that higher hourly wage
and they wouldn't leave the agency but
there are nurses that want that
stability sure and but they can't leave
they couldn't find the job well it's not
that they couldn't find a job it's that
they can't come to the district once
they've done a shift without the
district
paying
solvin thank
you got to get in position here um the
um do you have an idea how much it would
cost the Manchester School District to
buy out one of these nurses so it
depends on the contract um so last year
they had nine to 10 different agencies
just because not even a single agency
can St our school district so we had N9
to 10 different agencies and each
contract was different there were one or
two that did not have buyouts and
non-competes in there so I'm not going
to say that all nursing agencies do this
it's not the case um the ones that are
actually like interum the ones that are
more local to the state do not tend to
have this practice it's the outof state
ones that tend to do this they're also
the ones that don't tend to vet the
nurses so this is where it really
becomes a problem
um so
it can go anywhere from $5,000 to
$20,000 per nurse depending on their
their LNA LPN RN their degree their
experience um that's why such a range
for even just 20 to 22 to come over as a
direct hire it's between 100 and
$400,000 thank you all right
representative lir did you have a
McKenzie uh thank you Mr chair thank you
for coming today so one of the things um
that you mentioned is the cities and
towns inability to compete because of
the cost of advertising and recruiting
recruiting
workers why do you think that
is have you looked at school district
budgets but we're paying for it one way
or the other right we're paying for it
one way or the other it's a matter of
what people want to put into the school
district budget for advertising and and
direct hiring versus what we end up
having to pay on the back end and
basically asking forgiveness because we
need these
positions versus hey can we get this so
we can staff these positions and
advertise to get them a lot of people
don't want to approve the money upfront
so then we're having to pay it on the
back end okay and represent flan again
no no I'm all set representative Granger
thank you Mr chair so you mentioned
these two plus year non-competes is that
only between the agency and their
customers or does it apply to the nurse
if she's going for work elsewhere so
they can go elsewhere but if they like
that facility they can't work there for
that amount of time without the
organization paying okay so just to be
CLE like if so if you didn't want to
work at the school and you wanted to get
a nursing job somewhere else that would
be okay as long as you didn't work a
single shift there okay thank you I I
would like to add it was not uncommon
when I was an agency nurse to be sent to
multiple locations for a single shift
preventing me from then doing
that represent stop um thank you U thank
you for coming and thank you for taking
the our questions um can you answer for
me what motivates someone who is a nurse
um to use a staffing agency rather than
just looking for a job flexibility money
there's many benefits to an agency I'm
not against agencies whatsoever um you
have the ability to say I want to work
work this day this day this day but not
this day this day this day if you have
somebody who has great benefits but
doesn't make a lot of money hey I can do
an agency job I can bring down great pay
and I can take this week off when I want
this week off when I want I'm not
relegated to work these holidays it's
great flexibility it's great pay and
that's where a lot of nurses are
attracted it's when nurses want
stability that they're willing to take
the lower paying jobs where we have a
lot of our short ages and so these
agencies even though they have these
great things and can already attract are
then trapping those nurses that are
willing to do these other jobs that
less R McKenzie question thank you Mr
chair uh you may not be able to answer
this but uh do you have any sense of of
the wage that a nurse gets under the
agency environment
and the wage plus benefit cost um that
somebody would get uh be entitled to in
a uh in the city of Manchester for
instance that we get healthare and
pension benefits and all that stuff is
that if you if you put all that stuff
together and you add 30 or 40 maybe more
than that
percent uh to a person's salary is it
comparable no so it's about um depending
on the position it can be anywhere from
like 10,000 to3 to
$40,000 annually difference and that's
if you take like in the school district
if you take the annual salary plus the
benefits um because our benefits run
about
52.3% um if you take that in comparison
to the hourly salary of an agency nurse
um the agency nurse still makes quite a
bit
more so there is quite a benefit to
working for an agency there it's not
like they're going to be like completely
out of business there's not going to be
this Mass Exodus from agencies represent
proud thank you Mr chairman um do you
have any insight into why there's such
variation in the buyout terms amongst
the various agencies that Manchester
School District works with u mean
couldn't the school district put a
boilerplate or maximum buyout
requirements into the RFP and say you're
not even allowed to bid unless you meet
these requirements I mean would that
cause other problems like they wouldn't
actually be able to fill the positions
or I mean I I that's why I'm trying to
wrap my head around is is why isn't this
just solved at the RFP stage so I can't
speak to the RFP stage or the attorney
that did the contracts I do know that a
lot of times when we put out the RFP
there's only one two or three that they
accept however because of our size we're
the largest District in the in the state
um we end up having to go then to
multiple as like a last Stitch just to
get people in and these agencies they
each have their own
requirements so I can't speak to the
negotiation of that because I'm not part
of that thank you representative Ling
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question uh when you worked for an
agency nurse um were you aware of how
these agencies generated Revenue did you
know how they made
money no not at the time okay thank you
represent stop um thank you um I um I
would appreciate it if you would you
know because you are a school nurse um I
would appreciate it if uh could you give
us um an idea of um what School nurses
do you're not just putting Band-Aids on
kids um and and IEP requirements and um
potential for litigation when nursing is
not staffed in schools thank you yeah so
nurses are actually not required in the
state of New Hampshire however um we do
like you said a lot more than Band-Aids
on booboos
we do tube feeds we do suctioning we
obviously do meds we do triage uh
seizure kids a lot of times we do drugs
alcohol fights
um catastrophic injuries we see
especially at the high school level um
we run the gamut we obviously students
have IEPs a lot of those students have
individual nurses with them who do tube
feeds suctioning or with the students
all day long that's why we have such aot
we're basically a mini Hospital in the
Manchester School District
um significant amount of care that our
students
need all right see you no further
questions U represent
C so you mentioned in your Mr chair
thank you uh you mentioned in your
testimony that there are other agencies
that don't require this in New Hampshire
the ones that are here in the state so
clarify if I'm wrong but it sounds like
uh there are other vendors let's say
that do not do what is this bill would
correct let's say is that correct that's
correct every agency does their own
thing so there are a handful that do not
do this and to them I find that very
commendable I think that's the right way
to do things how unfortunately that is
not how everybody does things and I'm
finding the majority of the ones that
are that unkind um are from out of state
and actually um somebody asked about
agencies trying to recruit nurses who
are currently working I routinely get
messages and phone calls from an agency
while I'm working
FYI for followup so just to ask the
question would you support the
Manchester School District utilizing
only those new hampshire-based
organizations to find a better situation
to not have to pass this bill to fix the
issue itself if they had the budget
allotment to do
so okay thank you
okay yes ma'am go ahead thank you um one
last question are you aware of any other
states that have similar legislation
that is aimed at um ending these
non-competes for nurses staff nurses
yeah actually the language in this um
bill is modeled after Illinois and Iowa
who enacted the legislation in 22 and
23 represent kale chair and thank you
for taking my question uh can you tell
us if that legislation in those States
has improved the situation with Staffing
that I don't know
follow up yes sir okay before this is my
question I had before you told me about
the other states um so the out of state
uh nurses are most of them are probably
coming here for a short term to make
higher wages and then go home and would
let would be not so in inclined to
settle down in New Hampshire uh for
whatever reason and but so the the
hiring challenge I think is that because
we're not training enough nurses here in
New Hampshire so the nurses themselves
are not based out of state the agencies
are based out of state they're
recruiting New Hampshire nurses by
advertising and paying the money to
advertise and get ahead of the public
entities like the correctional system
and the school districts and stuff like
that to basically head hunt and get them
for the higher cost to make their money
and so that we don't get them and many
of the agency nurses I spoke with
thought that they were applying for the
district and that the agency was acting
on behalf of the district and they felt
quite deceived after the fact learning
that they weren't actually working for
the district I see thank you all right
thank you ma'am for your testimony I
please thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee I hope I'm not the last
speaker before lunch but if I am I'll
try try and be brief thank you sir I am
here um this a this afternoon on behalf
of the American Staffing Association and
we are concerned about housebuilt
386 um and you heard some uh very good
testimony by Rick Peterson and for many
of the same reasons um we are concerned
about those sections on page
two uh lines three through well
certainly nine and and and then there
there's the exceptions that uh 1 through
a through C uh permit
um but we're we're dealing with contract
law um and the contracts between the
facilities and the
agencies and um this would be certainly
an intrusion an invasion of that private
contract between those uh
I don't know whether uh disclosure is
the is the right step it might be uh for
purposes of informing the employee in
this situation um that might be the
redress up front rather than having no
redress on the back end when a facility
can just cancel a a a contract without
any consequence and that's really what
is at stake here contract law and being
able to uphold
that
um I won't go into all of the the you
know experiences and details that that
Mr Peterson went into I thought they
were uh ex very well
explained um
by putting in the language on the page
two lines 3 through n you're taking
flexibility out of the relationship and
I think we heard Mr Peterson talk about
that flexibility and the importance of
that relationship and being able to
to
deliver in this case nurses for
different
facilities um I think
too this issue is
diminishing it obviously spiked during
Co it was a very dire situation in in
many instances
around the country not just New
Hampshire and what we are seeing and I
can provide to the committee um later
self-correcting the the demand is not as
high the the um profits are not as high
uh for for agencies and so um we're
seeing a return to a normal time
time
um with that Mr chairman um I think I
would conclude my
remarks I ask the committee to consider
that fairness in the contractual
relationships between two
entities it is uh you know two years ago
this committee was involved in Senate
Bill
149 that passed into law and brought
about a new registration process for any
uh staffing agency that wanted to
operate in the state of New Hampshire
and that was a good
step and it put restrictions on staffing
agencies it didn't put restrictions on
the facilities but it put restrictions
on on the staffing agencies and so there
is accountability out there and you know
we we need to see if this is going to
work the current law as well as the
postco era that we're we're now in I'd
be happy to try and address any
questions and if I'm unable to I will
endeavor to find you answers all right
sir thank you for your testimony do we
have any questions represent
suvan I I guess I'm a little bit
troubled in that
um I can um I can see the point of the
agency um not wanting to um lose an
employee first day after the the nurses
assigned to a facility
um and I'm persuaded by uh Mr Peterson's
um good business sense that if you don't
treat your clients well they're not
clients anymore um I'm also persuaded
that um there's some abuse out there um
that U some of these agencies are taking
advantage um are um being grossly
unreasonable and probably don't care
about that business
relationship um and I'm trying to figure
out how to fix what's
broke
without um destroying what's
working um
thoughts I I I think they're you know
I'm I'm not the expert in the Staffing
World representative Sullivan but I'm
I'm certainly willing to take that very
good question back to uh my client you
know I it's almost seems like this
language in
386 is a sledgehammer being used on an
issue that perhaps only needs
um scalpel I don't know um maybe not a
good
um com com comparison but I you know I I
think perhaps if if something needs to
be done I think this can be worked on
and and developed without just putting
the sledgehammer onto the uh
relationship all right follow up uh
please for follow up I I I intend to
also call our um nursing home
administrator who um has suffered under
the weight of the agency nurses um but
I'm sure he's grateful that the agencies
are there to provide the nurses
otherwise he wouldn't be able to staff
the nursing home he'd have to throw
people out right residents out um so um
would like to get his thoughts I'd like
but bottom line is there it appears to
me something needs to be
fixed and I think we need uh some help
figuring out how to fix what's the it
sounds like these out ofate agencies are
a problem
um it sounds like the New Hampshire
agencies perhaps are not so much it
would be oh I'm sorry I didn't mean go
ahead goad it would be interesting to
learn and and perhaps we can from the
office of professional lure and
certification
whether some of the agencies that the
the previous speaker uh listed off are
have registered as as they're required
to under the new New Hampshire law I I
see it for followup sir yes I see a head
nodding is that meaning that they are
you represent Flanigan thank you uh Mr
chair good to see you Mr berky um
I see first of all I don't see this bill
solving the problem that they're trying
to solve and let me throw some things at
you and see what your
responses um there's a notification
issue I think the employees need the
nurses need because they're not Mr
Peterson's employees they're contractors
with them so there needs to be some
notification up front with the nurse or
nurses that says that if they do decide
to stay there or if there's some
discussion
that there's a relationship that Mr and
I'm just using as an example Mr P
Peterson uh and the facility have that
there's some negotiation so it's not
really non-compete it's really
notification that is there is there a
question at the end of this yeah I'm
getting there I'm getting there because
and now look at that now you I'm having
a brain fart um the uh the other thing
is that um oh God what did you do that
for never mind
there and I'll
ask would you like to ask a question
while I I would respond to that by just
saying that you know I I I think perhaps
there are some issues that can be worked
on and and along with what
representative Sullivan was was aiming
towards um so I think between you know
if if there's going to be a subcommittee
or the full committee we would be more
than welcome to work with this group to
see if there's a a solution out there
okay thank you representative pro thank
you Mr chairman um if we were to add a
requirement that all government rfps uh
need to specify uniform maximum buyout
for all the biders all the agencies that
want to do business under that RFP do
you think that would be their affect
their ability to get RFP responses and
actually fill the positions or do you
think that would just level the playing
field and maybe fix I think the problem
that Manchester had which is they didn't
think about this in
advance I I I think it would bring some
light to the issue without a doubt and
and whether it would be a a fix
probably not 100% but it would be a step
in the right
direction thank you represent Flanigan
for a followup no it's okay I I got I
got a a procedural issue with you after
this bill this is done all right thank
you I look forward to
that okay sir thank you for your
question thank
call Paul Dingle
Paul Pam
Dingle I'm sorry ma'am absolutely if you
could state your name and uh who you
affiliation with uh my name is Pam
denapoli and I'm with the uh New
Hampshire school Nurses Association New
Hampshire Nurses Association um I only
put two hours in the meter so I'm not
going to go through my testimony I
already submitted it in writing but um I
just want to kind of go through
summarize some of the key points that I
heard so one of the things that the the
last gentleman just said was that when
we had covid it really destabilized our
Healthcare work environment we really
had to rely on agency nurses to fill
those vacancies we brought in many many
nurses from out of state because there
weren't enough Supply in New Hampshire
so that model worked during an emergency
the model also works in areas that are
usually lower waged and difficult work
environments and I think you heard
School nurses you heard prison you heard
nursing home so agencies feel a really
important role um but what they also do
is D stabilize so what we have to do our
three things is we need a sustainable
permanent Workforce in New Hampshire we
need a Workforce that is has freedom of
movement and we need a Workforce that's
Innovative and so you need permanent
staff to do that um one of the things
that uh the FTC rule was um mentioned
and the key point in that it says that
it prohibits employers from entering
into non-compete agreements with workers
so what this bill does is it fills that
loophole so one of the things that this
bill does is look for loopholes so in
terms of your question 33 other states
have uh filed similar legislation and
nine have um totally banned um
non-compete so it's certainly when the
FTC wrote this it was supposed to go
into effect in September
2024 and um still pending but what the
reason it's pending is that there's a
lot of uh lawsuits around the loopholes
so what this is to do is to really
preemptive um strike against any uh
suits um it pro it promotes fundamental
freedom of workers to change jobs that's
important um and the reason that and I
think that this was asked around a lot
of times the reason that nurses so I
taught it UNH for 20 years
and students want the ability to change
Freedom now this generation so we used
to call them travel nurses and you know
every once in a while there'd be a nurse
who would say I want to move to Hawaii
and work and they would get one of these
agency contracts and they would move to
Hawaii and work for a year then come
back to New Hampshire so what's happened
during covid was that nurses realized
the um higher wages they could get from
this covid emergency they would travel
from CMC to the Elliott and be travel
nurses get a higher wage get a housing
sttip end so it really became an issue
that nurses realized what they were
finally being able to to get for their
worth what the last gentleman said was
there's a market correction so now
nurses they had their opportunity to go
hospitals realized that they don't want
to pay 125% of what they were paying
before for agency nurses so both the
supply is going down and the demand is
going out Hospital Association got
together to say we're not all going to
pay this agency fee anymore we have to
all work together to bring it down the
problem is that there's a nursing
shortage there's not a staffing shortage
because we know with nursing agencies
they can get the staff to fill the
vacancies so where are they getting
these people and that's the thing is
that they're they are out there
recruiting and retaining and that's
really important point and then the last
thing I want to say is that not all
contracts have not competes so I spoke
to the hospital Association none of
their contracts have non-competes so uh
when I talked to the CNO at Dartmouth
she said any nurse who wants to work at
at Dartmouth can work at Dartmouth the
difference I think you can see is that
if I'm a nurse who's going to get out of
a contract and work at Dartmouth is a
lot different than a nurse who's going
to get out of a contract and work at the
Manchester School District so nurses
want to work in acute care so if they
come into the state they work at
Dartmouth they realize what the
beautiful area is up there they can
easily get out of those contracts
because Dartmouth doesn't sign a
non-compete and neither do the other
hospitals in the state so this is really
to those low hardto fill places like
nursing homes like schools like prisons
and like home health so we really there
has and the final conversation was about
how can we balance this bill and there
has to be there has to be a place for a
gencies or we're really going to
experience the nursing shortage and not
just the Staffing shortage and we have
to figure out what is the role of our
permanent and we're doing the nursing
the uh New Hampshire nurs Association is
doing a lot of work with the healthcare
Workforce coalition to try to figure
these things out so this bill why it's
not going to solve all the problems like
I think you said over there it's a good
first step and we have to really look at
those little things that are barriers to
our Workforce and once we can Peck away
at those we can have a more sustainable
and permanent Workforce so those are
just my summary comments I think from
the good discussion that you had here
today thank you and you emailed that to
us already correct I did thank you yep
are there any
questions how could there be I think you
had every question in the book than
seeing no questions thank you ma'am I
appreciate you coming down and letting
us listen to you thank you thank
you all right having no more pin cards
seeing no more questions or comments I
close this hearing you now have 35
lunch
okay and I received emails from the
state
okay because this was published last
calendar all right let me um Mr chair I
got dropped from the email list too and
had to complain so it might not just be
just me that got dropped from the email
list
accidentally okay I I well I got dropped
from the labor committee email list
accidentally at the start of the new
term for some reason all right what
we're going to do is we're going to
recess for lunch
right when we recess come on up and
we'll talk about how we work it rather
than keep everyone here all right so see
you
Roger
e
everyone I'm hope you enjoyed your n
nice long leisurely lunch
and we did go from 29 minutes to 36
minutes
and so we're making progress not not
dramatic progress but I do appreciate
your your patience and
diligence um I'd like to open the
hearing on HB 248 relative to notice and
update requirements regarding state
employee investigations we have with us
our very own representative Jack
Flanigan to introduce the bill as the
sponsor sir over to you thank you Mr
chairman and as a little piece of paper
here says my name is Jack Flanigan I
represent Hillsboro 45 which is Hollis
Brookline Mason and Greenville which are
border towns in the state um position on
the bill I better support it because I
introduced it um I got to be careful
because the cases that I'm going to talk
about haven't been adjudicated
completely but I'm going to share you uh
some information that is probably not
necessarily out of the public but on a
specific individual that's been
suspended for it'll be year in
April they have attempted four grand
juries and uh the most recent
one uh they found that he deleted an
email and he shared some driver's
license information to his
boss and this is all instigated by the
executive
branch it just so happens that his wife
who was a judge refused to uh hear cases
because there was some issue with it
relates to the Attorney General's office
and she was suspended
too um which led me to this bill because
the uh the bill basically puts
parameters for the executive branch as
it relates to suspending an employee and
the representative from uh not represent
like us but the individual that
represents the state employees union has
given me an amendment of the bill that I
may talk to him about later as it
relates to the collective bargaining
agreement and how it matches with what
they have so the long and short of it is
the the people that um that I referenced
had never been given notice they never
given why they were uh suspended with
pay one of them has been being paid a
year with without notice although they
trumped up something here as it relates
to deleting an email Andor um uh the
whole sharing information uh with his
boss um who needed the information
so um I'm sort of constrained on talking
about the names but I want to make sure
that if it happens again any Town state
employee would be given the courtesy of
notice why they're being suspended I
believe there's also a review period
every 90 days to go over what's happened
and not happened um and again I'd be
better prepared Mr chairman if I had
received notice of my individual bill
but um I I just don't want it happening
again I don't think the uh executive
branch should have that kind of power
over the employees without due process
and that's pretty much what I can tell
you about the bill and who who's been
s thank you Mr chairman thank you
brother
Flanigan um I don't see any mention in
this uh uh bill of uh the executive
branch this would pretty much apply to
any employee correct any state employee
yes any state yeah okay thank you um
just to further answer your question
though is I mean if there's a manager
out there he would be considered part of
the executive because he works for
ultimately the governor
okay by
default and I do look forward to
collaborating with you on further labor
matters we are in the labor committee
and we do know they named the county
after you Sullivan County because of
your generosity and giving him the
land any other questions I I do have one
question in your in your this doesn't
exist already I mean this is like
so in your research it doesn't I mean OS
would have told me it existed already so
in this case I mean I I I will tell you
one on-one if you would like but I'm not
going to say publicly of the people but
you if you put two and two together you
can figure out who they are um and um so
I don't want some you know defense
lawyer or prosecutor coming knocking on
my door saying you know what did you say
what do you know okay um fair enough but
I just find it I guess put this way I
thought it was totally unfair of how
they were
treated okay any other questions yes
ma'am hi thank you and thank you Jack
would take oh representative that's okay
so it you feel sufficient to just have a
letter written up uh saying that they
can let me see here how do you put it
spended pay show the written notice
would be sufficient and and how many
days
should that be
given for the if they suspending
somebody they'd have to give them
written notice okay prior to the
suspension you're saying or at the same
time at the same time and the reality is
is without that written notice it's sort
of like you get a job right you get a
job they give you a letter say hey
congratulations we hired you um in this
case it's hey we're suspending you but
you need a formal process which would be
okay oh yeah represent K go ahead thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr Flanigan
uh I'm not sure I'm not an attorney uh
but is it possible that giving a the
reason for the suspension could
jeopardize the
investigation you me the RE from from my
perspective you mean well I mean just
legally you know if you're if you're
investigate follow up explanation yeah
yeah thank you sir so if you mean if I
were investigating something that I
thought you did correct and I wanted to
be sure to protect the evidence that
might exist from disappearing or
something else happening maybe would it
be uh appropriate for me not to tell you
why I'm investigating you so I could
better find that information do I I
probably to tell a judge or somebody
what's up right well um to answer your
question a lot of the stuff would be
exculpatory in other words it it'd be if
especially if there's legal action you
uh you you would have to receive some
formal notice of what you did wrong I
mean especially if there's going to be a
termination involved so I mean I see
your point um especially when it deals
with labor law there may be uh some
constraints but as I think the right
thing to do is be telling the person
what they did right or wrong especially
right in these days because this very
rarely happens but wrong specifically in
this issues so yeah I mean I'm I don't
disagree with you but I I see a point
but I don't necessarily agree with you
thank you yeah all right thank you for
introducing this bill and uh if I could
please yeah
yeah Mr chairman with your permission
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Bob blazel I am a senior lobbyist with
the state employees Association here in
conquer um I am on the um card as uh
being opposed to the bill but I I do
want to be clear that I I absolutely
agree with the sponsor's
intent and when you all get this um
around my proposed amendment what you
will see is the bill as produc as as as
introduced um this language already does
exist within the collect the bargaining
agreement if you flip on the other
side um of the paper I showed you you
will see that currently the the bargain
language um if someone's under
investigation they're supposed to get an
update every two
weeks so if you are um a state employee
that's that's that's a member of the
Union that is the current language if
you're under investigation
um so the way the bill is written would
essentially be a major step backwards
for state employees um so you know if I
always thought like rather than killing
a bill if if you can come to like an
agreement U somehow of a of a compromise
um that's why I have that Amendment
before you um because it basically says
um 90 days um or language and a collect
the bargain you agreement whichever is
sooner um understanding now I think I
have a little bit better understanding
of what representative Flanigan um is is
saying then then maybe I would amend my
Amendment and and say for executive um
employees and state employees um that it
mirrored the collective bargaining
language where they get notified every
two weeks as to what's going on with
them and I think they deserve to know um
rather than uh 90 days so um I I hope
you I hope I was clear um that this
would as as written um as introduced
would be a major step backwards for
state employees please consider the
amendment um and further consider it if
you want to Encompass absolutely
everybody whether you're the executive
level or not if you feel that um any
employee what regardless of your status
um you should be notified every two
weeks um that's what we feel is
appropriate I'll take any
questions represent
Salin thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question if if
I'm not and I don't oppose anything you
said about changing it to two weeks um
but uh if it went through as drafted my
impression is that a collective
bargaining agreement um can um provide
um a an enhanced uh set of um terms and
conditions over what the law might
so I would probably want to talk to a
lawyer a labor lawyer I was in labor but
I'm not a lawyer um but I it it seems to
me that um the the bill as proposed
would not interfere with um the um uh
what's in the collective bargaining
agreement you would still enjoy an
enhanced version of the notification
rights do
you what what are your thoughts on that
so uh to be absolutely clear I am not an
attorney okay um so I agree with your
assessment of you want to talk to a
um I'm assuming since there're be uh
negotiation signed off with the state
that if they have um language within
their collective bargaining agreement
that if it's different then say if you
pass this that the collective bargaining
agreement will prevail I don't know I
don't know the answer to that um that's
above my pay grade um but I will I will
I know a lot of very good skilled labor
attorneys and I'm I'm sure um I can get
you an answer very very
soon followup for a followup I I I'm
aware that we do have two attorneys
sitting in the back of the room they are
department of labor attorneys whether
they're they consider themselves labor
attorneys I'm not
sure I I think um overall my my sense is
that I think we all want an employee
regardless of status to have appropriate
notification that's my sense and so I'm
happy to work with uh the employee uh
sorry all right one more thing Mr
chairman I'm sorry I um I did send this
amendment to representative fingan this
morning and I'm very happy uh to to work
with him and his intent uh to make sure
that his goal and our goals uh coincide
and everybody's happy all right great no
thank you appreciate it appreciate the
testimony uh represent FL do you want to
okay raise my hand and swear and
again
oh have
Sor oh yeah we will
yeah thank you Mr chairman and thank you
to the Liberty uh of my fellow U
committee members um I don't have a
problem with the amendment that he's got
because it defaults either one or the
other depending and for example in this
case it's a collective bargain agreement
that already has it but my reference was
the executive branch or the executive
employees are not covered by the CBA so
his his Amendment would cover both CBA
employees and executive employees so I
don't have a problem with that and if
you if you know I can put in the
amendment today and get it out and for
the next except if you'd like beautiful
okay thank you very much for allowing
thank you and uh is there anyone in the
room from labor that that might want to
comment on this if they filled out a pin
here Mr Garrison sir good afternoon
thank you John garan uh general counsel
for the Department of Labor um as
representative Sullivan accurately
pointed out I I am a lawyer for the
Department of Labor I don't consider
myself a labor lawyer when it comes to
Labor Relations um labor relations with
the state is not within the purview of
the Department of Labor we'd point you
to the um to D or the division of
personnel for more questions on or for
answers to your questions on how
employee discipline processes and time
frames
work okay but if you have those
questions I'm happy to Ferry them over
to dop to provide answers yes sure thank
you Mr chairman um do we not have
anything in rules or 275 that specifies
um for suspensions or
whatnot not in uh the Department of
Labor's rules no not not pertaining to
to State Employees thank you thank you m
okay thank you for on the spot testimony
yes all right see no more pin cards
and no more uh testimony representative
Flanigan yes if you could put that in
next
okay we'll execute at 1300 next
Tuesday 1
pm can we just talk about this bill for
a second amongst
ourselves uh sure
yeah what percentage of the state
employees that would be covered by this
CBA no this this bill seems like a reply
to the entire state employees what
percentage would be under CBA as for
isn't it single digits like 10% I don't
I don't yeah state employees are
unionized
question and another do you have a
question yeah another question if you
don't mind thank you it's the OSS or you
decid to put this new section in 21-
1-i is all about Department of
administrative Services it just seemed
like a weird place to stick this in and
not somewhere else in labor do you did
you have any say in that I just wonder
if the people
from the Department of Labor have a
bigger picture of how how the uh rsas
are numbered would have an opinion on
anybody lot like insurance and you know
doesn't include Labor uh but uh you know
probably a little bit of buildings and
things like that um but
uh I'm you know it's administrative so I
don't I guess they would have coverage
over someone has to approve the PDA
isn't that the governor it represents
Soloman do you have input the uh public
employer labor Labor Relations Board
actually covers the uh
um the bargaining rights and such for
public employees in New Hampshire not
the Department of Labor so uh that week
actually ran into that with one of the
bills we've discussed um but um uh
it I I'm not sure exactly what section
of uh law this uh administrative
Services is um but um it may very well
please um represent that's that's a very
good question um why it's under admin
Services um section 21i 42 relates to
personnel and if you go to 21- i42 Roman
numeral 1 it says managing a centralized
Human Resources processing operation
unit which shall provide for the
recruitment appointment compensation
promotion transfer layoff removal and
discipline of state employees so I
believe it is in the right
section thank you very much that's
helpful great thank you appreciate the
input thanks for bringing it
up question represent aani thank you
thank you Mr chairman does the go have
um do you have eyes on this RSA 21i do
you guys enforce anything that comes
so if a state employee was it follow
up well they can answer the first
question then for follow
okay good afternoon I'm Danielle Albert
I'm the Deputy Commissioner of the New
Hampshire Department of Labor um by and
large the department doesn't enforce
anything that falls under 21i my
recollection and I can um follow up in
writing just to verify as I believe
there is one small
provision at
21i that dictates ongoing Indemnity
payment or uh I'm sorry ongoing salary
continuation in certain types of workers
compensation cases for um certain types
of state employees but otherwise we have
General understanding of the statutes
existence as you know state employees
ourselves but we're not administering to
or have jurisdiction over any of its
Provisions other than that very small
comp piece followup for followup sir so
if a employee was AG grieved by this
they wouldn't go to you there would go
to as that La that laid them off or
disciplined them yes it would be between
them and their agency and in general for
State um CL classified employees or for
state employees if there is a dispute
about disciplinary action that was taken
which can include suspension um written
warnings things of that nature there's a
dispute process which is administered
through the Personnel appeals
board or heard by the Personnel appeals
board excellent thank you thank you
you're welcome then if you guys could
fill out the pink cards and
representative plig again if you could
awesome and this this uh concludes the
hearing on HB 248 we'll reconvene in 15
couple you don't want that one I got one
from
hilard no no company that sellor product
[Music]
to
e
still out a pin
card a pin
like to call the committee to
order and open the hearing on
hb280 relative wage payments and
representative turkot you're here to
introduce your bill I am thank you Mr
chairman the floor is yours sir uh
what's that I said the floor is is yours
sir oh very good thank you very much uh
good afternoon members of the labor
committee uh I am representative Len
turkot I represent the District of
straford County 4 which are the towns of
straford and
barington um I served on this committee
my first three terms in the house I'm in
my fifth term now uh the bill before you
um has a little bit of history on it and
I will say that over my three terms on
the labor committee that uh We've uh
we've had multiple bills come up uh
addressing this particular section of
the
rsas um one of them in particular has
come up many times that
was bills on the the use in of payroll
cards matter of fact we had one last
term this committee ited it um we the
payroll cards I I believe are an awful
solution for wai employees to uh to be
paid um but on my last term on labor
again we had a a bill on the on the
payroll cards and it ended up in a
committee of conference which I was a
member of at that time uh Senator Carson
represented the committee of conference
from the Senate side and they were in
favor of increasing the use of the
payroll cards uh we in the house were
not uh the committee of conference ended
without
concurrence but I told Senator Carson at
the time that uh at some point in the
future I'd profer legislation that would
remove hundreds of words of regulatory
language which the employers uh must
currently de employers and employees
must currently de uh deal with and
that's what this legislation does um I
had originally told her I thought it
would be about 750 words turns out to be
430 words of regulations that are
removed
um couple things I want to point out
before I talk about what the goal of it
is um the enforcement by the department
Remains the Same with the exception of a
single line and that is if you go to
page two on the bill uh line 26 it talks
about the repeal of 2731
a3b and what that does is uh that RSA
says payment of wages by checks on fin
financial institutions that is not
convenient to the place of employment uh
the only reason that is eliminated
because in the 430 words that we do
eliminate that was one of the issues um
that was eliminated other than that the
regulatory language
remains so what are the goals of the
bill first it's to reduce regulatory
burdens on our businesses all businesses
not a specific
industry um we're not here to or I'm not
here to promote special interests of
those who produce or in the business of
the payroll
cards and above all we want to allow the
free market and the employer employee
relationship to decide how and in what
form wages will be paid if the employee
agrees with the employer they have their
Arrangement without interference without
government bureaucracy or mandates that
now you will see
uh one other thing mention before I
continue on here at the be very
beginning of the bill on line three
there's existing language that remains
and that is um whether or not the
employer pays within 8 days or within 15
days that was actually in my second term
a u a bill I put through at the time it
you had to pay Within days unless you
had a special exception from the
department and I put in that bill to
make it every year uh if if the employer
wanted to pay every two weeks he could
do it that way
um so I I know in the past we've
heard um some of the reasons for not
doing this um well you know some people
don't have bank
accounts well what what I will say about
that I think there's probably less than
than the number of people in the state
the number of fingers on my hands that
don't have um bank
accounts um they need to and if they
don't they need to find an alternative
way uh to make that happen or the
employer if it's a valued
employee the employer can say hey I will
take care of you and we will pay your
wages in another form if they
the main as I said we eliminate 430
words and all those ways of how a
business must pay or an employer must
pay an employee is replaced by a single
paragraph and that paragraph is the
manner in which the payment is made
shall be determined by the employer the
employer shall honor before the first
day of employment inform the employee in
writing the manner in which payment
shall be made at any time an employer
intends to change its method of payment
each employee shall be given written
notice no less than 90 days prior to
that change now I anticipate a question
of maybe does that apply to all
employees some of the
employees guess what that's up to the
relationship I anticipate somebody's is
going to say well what happens if the
employer decides to pay their employees
in silver or
gold the employee can
there of course I will say that the
chance of this happening is about as
like likely as an employee being hit by
lightning we know that probably 98% of
all employees currently in the state are
paid by either automatic uh payroll
check the what if what about the
employer says I want to pay you in
Bitcoin I know one individual on this
committee is going to not like this
answer but I would say if I was the
employee I'd say run away from that
employer because his macroeconomic sense
isn't very good you don't want to be
involved with that
employer um so anyway that's basically
what the what the bill does simply Rel
eliminates a whole bunch of regulatory
burden puts the employer employee
relationship um
together and that's it I'd be happy to
take any questions any questions
representative kill thank you represent
chair and thank you uh brother
turkot um does it it sounds to me you'll
correct me if I'm wrong but it does
sound like agreeing to the gold and
silver or perhaps the kangaroo pelt uh
would be a condition of employment if I
don't want the kangaroo Pelt or gold and
silver if I want cash I I don't have any
recourse as a pro as an employee is that
correct no you absolutely have a
recourse your recourse is to either work
for Kangaroo pelts or grains of sand or
whatever the employer wishes to pay you
in again we know that
98% probably closer to 100% of
individuals are played by paid by
automatic payroll deposit or check so
but follow up for followup yes sir but
the the the choice is either work for
this employer who wants to pay me in
these other Fashions or not it's a
condition of employment which I think we
have found problematic in some of our
other
discussions uh such as union membership
or things like that if it's a condition
of employment or even uh uh tipped wages
we can't you know
tip pooling condition of employment is a
rather sensitive area in labor law as a
union member myself of 40 years I will
say that most um any any employer that's
involved with a Union
contract having written lots of Union
language and been involved with that
stuff for eight years of my career um
I'm sure the Union contract will take
care of how payment is made if the
employer decided they were going to try
to pay their employees in kangaroo
pelts oh stop oh can I can I have
another may I have another yes sir you
may thank you sir um and again thank you
for your patience um it it does seem to
low open the door to payroll cards which
again we have this committee has as
recently as this year has voted against
and any and it doesn't seem to offer any
really protections to the employer to
the employee such as the bank account a
bank near near the place of employment
or it and do you know that there are a
lot more than 10 people in the state
that don't have bank accounts I'm I'm
volunteering at a food pantry tomorrow
and I could bet that maybe 10 of the
hundred people that will serve have a
bank account
and I guess would you believe I I would
to say I didn't hear much of a question
there but uh then I would say for those
10 individuals um they're obviously
getting paid
somehow representative
stop thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question if uh my question
is if an employer decides to pay their
employee in something that's not
considered legal tender or or
traditional funds like potatoes or
something how would you manage um
withholdings I know like a tax income
tax this bill does nothing to speak
about withholding none of those rsas
change none of the enforcement
mechanisms change the only thing this
changes is how the employer is paid uh
employees are paid again I'll say it
again we know that an majority of our
employers are not going to be paying
their employees in potatoes or kangaroo
skins they're going to be paying them
normally in legal tender what this does
liinatamberg chman thank you for taking
my question sure um I also have
bargained a fair number of collective
bargaining agreements and
um do you when you're when you've got
your union hat on um is
it the norm for you to say that the
employer can do whatever they the
employer
wants um I no longer have my union hat
on as a negotiator or representative of
my union like I did for8 years I am here
today speaking about removing 430 words
out of our current rsay that don't need
to be there followup please but would
you agree that this what this bill does
is it says the employer can do whatever
the employer wants
no
okay represent fton would this allow for
either more opportunities or an economic
employees that's kind of like a
macroeconomic question possibly I don't
I don't know the answer to
that representive King thank you Mr
chair um I'm reading through the portal
here and there's a lot of the same uh
sentiment of questions and I wanted to
see if you could answer it for me um it
says that there is um this would
unilaterally allow employers to charge
or change the way that an employee is
paid it would also make it uh a ailable
so that they could our employees could
inquire or get more fees when it comes
to getting their paychecks so could you
just mention that last that last line I
missed that last one yep yep the um it
the way that it's written there's a lot
of people are saying that this could
also make it so an employer could now
choose a payment option that would
require the employee to pay extra fees
to get their
paycheck possible yes but again what
this bill does is it
gets bureaucracy out of the employer
employee relationship that's the goal of
this bill again um as an employee I
don't have to work for American Airlines
I choose to work for American Airlines
because of the way I'm
paid um my Union
contract um and different things I don't
have to work for American Airlines I
could leave American Airlines and go
somewhere else if American came to me
tomorrow and said uh we're going to just
start we're going to start charging you
a 10% fee for the production of your
paycheck
so representative Granger thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
so in the bill it says the employee
shall be given written notice no less
than 90 days prior to the change what's
the purpose of that
line um
well let's just say the employer began
uh when the employee got hired and he
said we are going to be paying you with
papercheck okay so they sign their their
contractual the employer writes out this
is how we're going to get paid you're
going to get paid with a paper check
later on he decides it's more efficient
for me and most of my employees to pay
you with automatic payroll deposit I'm
going to do that so 90
days before they go to automatic payroll
deposit the employer would have to
inform his employees this is what I'm
going to do in 90 days thank you very
much you're welcome representative
sylvestro hi thank you sir and thank you
for taking my question
so who came up with this idea who thinks
it's the bureaucracy how many employers
came to you saying they were upset with
the restrictions would it be somebody
like representative avalani that came to
you and said hey I don't like the way I
want more control how I pay my employees
why is this an issue why is this an
issue
I I'll
reemphasize the reason I brought this
forward this was the result of a
um I don't want to call it a promise but
um something I said to the senator um in
a committee of conference because we
couldn't come to an agreement on
something and I said I will I missed it
by a session because I forgot last
session but I said I'm going to bring
you back and we're going to eliminate a
lot of this language so we can free up
the employer employee relationship
that's it nobody no specific individual
or specific business came to me this is
something that I've been wanting to do
since I was on labor
committee representative
Granger thank you Mr chair would you
believe that the former chair of this
committee will infantine also has
expressed that we should really just get
rid of this whole chapter or do
something similar to what you're
expressing this bill I would definitely
believe that having known will very well
again my goal originally was to go for
750 words to eliminate but uh I was
advised that maybe 430 would be better
for now so all right and representative
Clair thank you
um so the employee shall honor before
the first day of employment employ and
inform the employee in writing the
manner of which payment shall be made so
kind of going back to a person that may
not even believe in checking accounts or
savings accounts or being involved with
banks if you told me that I had to have
direct deposit is that a little
discriminatory I would say that would be
up between the employer and the employee
that's what a contract is um You can
call it discriminatory if you want um
but if I if you came to me and I said
hey look the only way I'm going to pay
you in my business is through automatic
payroll um AC whatever they call it
direct deposit and you said well I can't
do that you have to do something else
I'm going to say sorry this is how I run
my business this is the whole purpose of
this bill is to give the employer and
the employee the ability to decide how
that Arrangement is going to
work just a pleas followup just um so
that's
really I guess like you could say you
the your uh choice is to not take the
job right
exactly thank you
representa McKenzie do you have a
question I got
few uh can we representative drill down
into the section uh the deals on line 21
with uh Health and Welfare funds
collective bargaining agreements um and
more importantly the whole question
about um other agreements adopted for
the benefit of employees agreeded by
employees should be paid by the employer
within 30 days and that includes uh
Health and Welfare funds so
what is the net effect and maybe we'll
hear from the attorneys from the
Department of Le what is the net effect
of re of removing all of that language
that deals with when you get paid how
you paid uh how these things how these
funds are paid and then also um in the
collective bargaining environment um you
know this this recognizes that what is
your bill what what does this do when
you wipe all these sections out of the
out of the current law uh and how do
these things get paid and what is the
what precedent do the collective buing
agreements have considering they all
probably have languages Rel as it
relates to uh how they're going to get
paid that's a very lengthy question and
what I will do is I will go back and
look at those lines that you're talking
about and I will get back to the chair
of the committee with an answer on that
you there stop um thank you um as I look
at this um one of the concerns that I
have is that um an employer might write
something that looks like a check or a
check um we have a lot of uh regulations
on banking in the United States to
ensure that um the the that the money is
actually there to um to fulfill the
obligations of the person writing the
check Etc um
so how will you
guarantee that if um an employer is
paying um paying an employee that it's
actually uh something that can be
guaranteed and counted upon um by the
employee I'm not sure I understand your
question I mean you know my
representative kill could say okay I
have a bank and and just like
give people checks and then an employer
could write a check on the bank of
Cahill but there's no money in the bank
of kill that would be up to the
Department of Labor to enforce that's
got nothing to do with how the employer
and the employee arrange their payment
UPF front Okay thank you representative
Granger thank you Mr chair would you
believe that due to the fractional
Reserve nature of uh the American
banking system most of the money in the
there now you are going down a a very uh
all right let's discussion take a long
time would you believe Germaine please
would yeah re McKenzie M Mr chairman I I
I expect we're going to hear from the
Department of Labor relative yes we are
uh because I think it it it begs an
analysis of this section and the impact
this is going to have on on workers in
general and uh I don't think that the uh
sponsor is able to answer that he will
respond to that guess at some point but
Labor's on Labor's on tap thank you sir
represent
Alani thank you Mr chairman and welcome
home representative charot thank you uh
this is the best
committee um uh line 21 page two uh the
manner in which payment is made shall be
determined by the employer shouldn't
that say employer and employ
e
21 page two
okay as you did follow up for followup
you have reference status between the
employer and the employee wouldn't that
be better if it was spelled out
clearer than just the employer paying in
kangaroo
PS representative avalani anything that
you could do or suggest that makes this
clear I would be certainly open
all
right repres fling again thank you Mr
chair I it's not necessarily with this
uh Mr representative Tura
but it it bothers me because I know all
the people here pretty much did
representative
de did Linda throw Gino under the
bus
what yeah commenting about
representative avalani had something to
do with the writing of this
bill no that it it just seemed like you
somewhat of accusatory tone that it was
something that he wanted because he owns
his own business and I've owned my own
business too no I I did not get that
sensing okay I just want to make sure it
wasn't that's all you okay wasn't taken
that way great seeing no other questions
thank you representative appreciate your
before you step down representative if
if the committee wanted
to add as representative avalani said
and employer onto that as an amendment
that that would work for you just to
confirm absolutely as I said before
anything that I've worked with
representative avalani long enough to
know that if he's got a suggestion it's
probably a good one okay great thank you
thank you good afternoon again John
garrian uh General counsil Department of
Labor and with me is Deputy Commissioner
Danielle Albert uh the department is
neutral on the bill as always um uh we
do have four technical notes and
suggestions as it relates to uh the
Department's enforcement of these
Provisions um one is just a note which
is that typically a department penalty
for violation of RSA
27543 um like most of our penalties is
up to $2,500 per violation um if the
violation is for failing to pay in full
or on time there is no warning required
uh for that however if the violation was
going to be for um a failure to say
provide this 90day notice of a different
payment method um that violation would
be subject to a 30-day warning and an
opportunity to um correct under our
statutes um second uh the statute
doesn't or sorry the bill doesn't speak
to this uh though the department often
enforces uh RSA
27549 with that provision says is that
employers have to retain certain records
and make them available to the
department for inspection including
amongst great many others records about
um wages and hours um and the time and
date of of pay and pay periods
um it doesn't specifically cover um
records pertaining to this notice of
payment method that would be a new type
of record um if the committee's intent
was to have those records um or sorry if
the committee's intent was to have do
the department to enforce the fact that
um employers would retain those records
we would have to have a line in RSA
27549 to cover that um employers under
that statute are required to retain
records for up to three
years um third uh the department does
have
concerns in that this bill um would open
up as we've discussed um when it comes
to Kangaroo pelts um it would open up
kind of non-monetary wage payment either
schemes or options that could be in kind
payments kind of barter based payments
commodity based payments um those those
types of payments they're difficult to
Value um and they're difficult for the
Department to enforce in terms of us
enforcing the pay of wages um the values
of those could be shifting uh or
subjective um it could also lead to uh
what we think is kind of increased
complaint complaints or claims for wages
um as kind of a uh a natural byproduct
of this it would have effect on our
workers compensation system as well one
of the core tenants of that system is we
need to figure out what the average
weekly wages in order to determine what
the benefit payments are um that is all
contemplating that wages are are paid in
some form of dollarss not uh King group
pelts as it were um I don't think you
know no insurance car would pay benefits
in 60% of your weekly kangaroo pelts um
so it would have Downstream effects on a
lot of the other functions of the
department um finally the bill seems to
remove um the kind of specific
protections or Provisions about um if
you're PID by check that it's got to be
drawn on a bank that's convenient to uh
the employee
or if you're paid in a pay card there's
a lot of protective elements to how pay
cards have to be issued what sort of
disclaimers have to be put out there
what recourses exist um that would all
go away so the department again would
would anticipate kind of increased
complaints um and increased enforcement
efforts I'm happy to take
questions counc ring thank you for your
testimony thank you Mr chair um I heard
in the testimony from representative
turkot that uh there's a possibility
that it might require by changing it uh
that the employee would receive a fee
I'm looking here in RSA 275 and it looks
like uh further on here in the chapter
it basically says that it cannot or
employees must be able to receive their
pay without a fee um also seeing here in
electronics fund transfer and also the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
also has regulations in the federal
level that would not allow for an
employer to use a service or a financial
thing that would require a fee so I'm
curious to see what you know
275 how that kind of correlates with
what the what it would do here yeah I
it's a it's an excellent question I'm
not going to comment on the cfpb or
their enforcement um there is still a
line in the bill uh direct your
attention to line seven on the first
page of the substantive text that would
still require um payment at no cost to
the employee Department would take that
as at no cost there are other specific
Provisions in the existing law about um
if it's a pay card there's got to be at
least one free opportunity to use that
pay card because fees on the pay cards
can uh they can they can add up or they
can um apply in different ways same with
the checks my understanding is that the
the convenient location of the check is
so you're not spending an hour of gas
driving to to process a check because
that ends up being a cut on the pay okay
followup for followup so what would the
recourse be If This Were to pass let's
say and an employee was charged a fe now
to receive their pay what would the
recourse be for the Department of Labor
uh if we felt there was sufficient
evidence that um there was an improper
fee charged uh we could bring an
enforcement action it would be a civil
penalty up to
$2,500 um if we felt that that uh fee
cut into the full amount of the wages we
could bring that without warning and the
employee themselves could bring a wage
claim at the department seeking kind of
an a private sense to to seek recompense
okay thank you representative kill thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr garrian um
if the 430 words were you know were
removed because this past would some of
these changes require you going to rules
and would that generate more
words I very lik I I couldn't articulate
specific rules off the top of my head
but um the rules we have a section of
rules it's our 800 rules that cover um
wage payments likely we would have to
look at those pretty carefully to make
them align with the statute follow up
for followup thank you
um what about the burden of converting
your kangaroo pelts to cash so that you
can buy groceries uh and secondary if
you if you do a citation of a civil
penalty of
pelts the department does not take a
position on the market rate of a repel
exactly exactly it fluctuates like
Bitcoin I can't stand it I have I'm
against
it represent McKenzie sir thank you Mr
chairman thank you uh hearing today so
the language Strikes Out starting at
seven uh line 17 and that section deals
with collective bargaining agreements
and pension trust funds and other
agreements and demand for payment for
administration um of Health and Welfare
and trust funds so I I I'm not I don't
I'm not able to read very well when I'm
listening to the people but does that
withraw does that take a whole section
of protection out as it relates to the
payment of those kinds of things in a
timely manner and does it reflect any of
the uh the agreements that are currently
in
place in collected buing agreements and
other things like that they're already
part of the law and they're protected I
don't
understand what the impact was taking
that out would be I guess is the
question uh yeah the department can't
comment on the overall impact that would
have on collective bargaining agreements
that's not an area that we that we
regulate um but just generally that
section I
guess
I would removing it have impact um it
would certainly change the law um in an
objective sense uh the Department's more
focus on this section and what we tend
to focus on in our enforcement efforts
when it is usually this kind of the top
part of that um of that section which is
uh whether checks that are drawn on
financial institutions have been issued
um in a convenient manner
um to their place of employment we don't
we typically don't don't get into the
collective bargaining aspects
all right and representative Granger
thank you Mr chair so the term buck as
in one buck that originally referred to
when we use deer skins in uh New
Hampshire to as an actual unit of trade
and I'm wondering that extended that
covered actually couple several hundred
years do you know if the Department of
Labor existed back when a buck referred
to a literal buck skin okay this is a
Germaine question in what way because
it's relative to we're talking about
kangaroo pelts and whether or not it's
okay to use kangaroo pelts as a form of
payment and the Department of Labor
probably if they existed back then then
they would have been regulating such
things so this is already let's stay to
the written text of the bill please okay
thank you are there any other questions
I I can say the department has existed
since 1894 I don't know what the common
payment schemes 1994 were thank you are
there any other questions yes ma'am
thank you thank you Mr
chair because I think my question would
be about how you enforce things now if I
had an issue cashing a check from an
employer now I assume I can go to you um
and then you help enforce my ability to
get paid is how does that if someone has
a complaint like that how does do you
mind in a brief way explaining what that
how that complaint progresses sure yeah
um if we receive a complaint like that
um we uh our wage or sorry our
Inspection Division staff will review it
um and they will uh investigate it and
and investigations can involve contact
with the employer can involve getting
records from the employer to see if this
has happened for other employees um
involve followup um interviews with that
particular employee other employees all
those interviews are confidential and
protected under the law so that
employees can be candid and information
they provide uh and ultimately it may
result in a proposed civil penalty or an
enforcement action brought by the
department to recover um both the wages
and perhaps uh punitive civil
penalties represent Flanigan and then
represent McKenzie thank you Mr chair
and I wasn't even going to bring up
beaver pelts but is this a problem not
beaver pelts but this whole change of
was there a problem in the statute that
you were having trouble with or was it
just something that people thought it
was too busy because I remember years
ago dealing with an argument about
payroll cards and that's now in statute
we're now getting rid of all of that
stuff and I'm just saying is is this
just an opportunity
to is it does it improve
anything uh I will
say um that the department does receive
uh a number of complaints and contacts
every year um from people complaining
about means and methods of pay payment
employees okay okay thank you and
represent McKenzie thank you uh I'm
sorry to kind of stall out on this issue
but I I would like to hear some point
from you uh as it relates to line 21
down to the end because in that section
there is a provision for a demand on
payment of Pensions and all of those
things which gets eliminated from the
reason so the so I would like to if you
could not I don't want to put you on the
spot but if you could come back to us
with some information as to how that
section would be impacted when we decide
to take all that out of the way and I
and I don't expect you to have a
comprehensive answer for that right now
I I I appreciate that expectation um
that
it's a it's an extremely good question
it involves a some very interesting and
nuanced areas of the law I'm happy to
look at that and get you a more comp
detailed answer I'm happy to distribute
that to I appreciate that that would be
great thank
you okay sir seeing one more question we
will turn it over to representative
alalani thank you Mr
chairman uh line 21 page two would in
your estimation um adding employees
after employer so it would be the manner
in which imp payment is made shall be
determined by the employer and the
employee would this section being
enforce I think it could reduce
some um misunderstandings between
employers and employees and reducing
misunderstandings um will reduce the
number of cases we will need to enforce
so that would be a good clarification
thank you Mr chairman thank you all
right all right sir thank you thank you
it seeing no further pin
cards and no further testimony no
questions I close the hearing on hb280
thank you so much for your input and
we've got six and a half minutes until
heard
e
good afternoon everyone I'd like to open
the hearing today on HB 487 relative to
providing employees with advanced notice
of the work schedule
go thank you um this is somebody else
who put we put in a pink card for
chairman uh one of my constituents so if
that's okay I'll have her join me okay
thank you uh chair kryon and members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity to testify today in support
of House Bill
487 which I've introduced to ensure that
hourly employees in New Hampshire
receive at least 7 days notice of their
work
schedules again my name is Erica de and
I represent the town of Hampton this
bill is especially important to
residents of Hampton because so many
people work in the service industry for
many workers especially those in retail
food service and other hourly Industries
the unpredictability of work schedules
is more than just an inconvenience it is
a barrier to economic stability and
upward Mobility
right now in New Hampshire there is no
requirement that employers provide
advanced notice of work schedules many
businesses do the right thing and post
schedules in advance but too often
workers are left in the dark until days
or even just hours before shift begins
imagine being a single parent who has to
arrange child care but you do not know
your hours until the last minute imagine
juggling multiple jobs trying to
schedule a doctor's appointment or
taking a class to improve your skills
and your prospects only to have your
shift change unexpectedly and without
warning these are not hypotheticals they
are the realities faced by thousands of
New Hampshire workers every day this is
a workers issue and it is also an
economic
issue unpredictable scheduling leads to
higher employee turnover lower Workforce
participation and greater economic
insecurity which ultimately hurt
business and our state's economy when
workers do not know their sched uals in
advance they cannot plan their budgets
they cannot seek additional work and
they cannot fully participate in our
economy HB 487 is a balanced and
reasonable solution it simply requires
that employers provide their hourly
employees with at least 7 days notice of
their schedule the bill does not apply
to businesses with fewer than 15
employees and makes exceptions for
unforeseen circumstances Beyond an
employer's control it also uh opts out
the uh medical field um it also this
bill protects employees from retaliation
from assert for asserting their right to
Fair notice I want to be clear that this
is not an anti-business bill in fact it
is entirely Pro bus when workers have
predictable schedules they have more
reliable more product they are more
reliable more productive and less likely
or likely less prone to leaving their
jobs reducing hiring and training costs
for employers it benefits businesses and
employees alike New Hampshire workers
should not have to live paycheck to
paycheck with no idea when they will
work next they should not have to choose
between keeping their job and caring for
their families HB 47 gives them the
basic Dignity of knowing when they are
expected to work nothing more and
nothing less I urge you to support this
Common Sense fair and economically sound
measure to bring stability and fairness
to our Workforce thank you and I welcome
any questions appreciate that thank you
representative lry thank you Mr chair
thankk you for taking my question um
regarding like seasonal businesses
landscapers lifeguards snow plowing
operations that would be very difficult
to give seven days notice if we don't
know when it's going to snow or maybe it
rains or does a day off or something how
would you square that that's a great
question so let's take those one at a
time I I heard lifeguards um I I would
imagine that they the lifeguards EST
State lifeguards right now don't
schedule according to the weather but I
I don't actually know that I'm happy to
find out um regarding
lifeguards regarding plowing I would
imagine that most of those people are
salary positions um but if they are not
we could certainly carve out an
exception that has to do with weather
related issues I'd be happy to consider
that as well this is really in intended
representative to Target the industries
where there is an element of
predictability I'd be happy to carve out
an exception for snow related um or
weather related emergencies and I think
actually there is a provision in the
bill that would apply to emergencies and
weather probably falls under that
category not so much the not so or acts
of
God thank you represent stop uh thank
you Mr chairman um representative are
you aware of any other states that have
passed similar
legislation there are numerous other
states that have similar legislation and
I can get you that list thank you thank
you and sorry I couldn't quite say thank
good okay seeing no other questions
thank you ma'am appreciate your input
thank you and this is uh one of my
constituents who also put in a pink card
her name is Li craige head okay thank
you and do you have testimony as well
yes okay
great um chair kraton and members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify today my name is Elise CAD I
move to New Hampshire from Maine in
January of
2024 thanks I was excited at the
possibilities and love living here I
have become involved in my community
including serving on the wonet high
school budget Committee in Hampton I've
been working at the same restaurant ever
since my move and I like my job I work
hard I take pride in what I do and I
want to build a stable future for myself
however most weeks I don't know my
schedule until Sunday evening and I'm
frequently called upon to be at work at
5:00 a.m. with less than 12 hours of
notice because of that I can't schedule
medical appointments without the risk of
having to cancel at the last minute
which is a real problem for me I can't
pick up shifts at other restaurants or
retail stores to supplement my income I
want to work more I want to earn more
and I want to build a better future but
not knowing my schedule makes picking up
extra work exceptionally difficult I
would move to another job but this
practice of late scheduling is pretty
common in the restaurant industry right
now we are in an economic environment
where it's not easy to get ahead but I'm
trying um I know I'm not alone there are
so many other workers like me who want
to do more but we are be but we are
being held back simply because we don't
have the ability to plan if HB 487
passes I would finally have the ability
to see my schedule a week in advance
that means I could schedule medical
appointments without stress and I could
pick up extra work elsewhere this bill
isn't asking for special treatment it's
about giving workers like me a fair shot
at ability and the opportunity to work
um as we can and need to please support
HB 487 and give workers like me the
ability to plan our lives finances and
Futures thank you yeah thank you for
your testimony and thank you for coming
down and talking to us course uh
McKenzie thank you Mr chairman and
thanks for coming in wasn't so bad was
it it was a little bad hey come on um
just a simple question really is uh did
you bring this forward to your employer
and say hey it makes it difficult for me
to plan ahead and and what was their
response um yes I did and many of my
co-workers have as well and we're often
just met with sort of poor excuses too
bad
yeah okay thank you represent McKenzie
and then representative Dro coming
appreciate it so in the course of uh
your work how often do you get a
schedule and then get called
off um I mean we don't get called off if
that's so you so you you you get the
employer will tell you if I could Mr J
follow up with this for follow up yes
sir thanks so you the employee will
schedule you and then they decide they
don't need you um so does that happen to
you very often uh no it doesn't um we or
she doesn't decide she doesn't need us
we just get our schedule and that'll be
our schedule for the week but we don't
get called off or
anything
okay representative Dro thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
question I just want to follow up on um
representative Flanigan's question I'm
not in this industry so I don't know is
this common amongst all restaurants or
do you just have a bad
employer um I mean as a young that I
don't have a bad employer but I mean as
a young 20 something most of my friends
are also in similar Industries and they
all sort of go through the same thing
so
okay yes sir mko thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question uh if
if you go have your shift and you show
up and it's kind of a slow night do they
do they sometimes tell you to go
home um no not in my experience no one's
been cut from the shift that's good
followup for a followup yes sir uh so if
you were otherwise engaged doing
something during the day and the boss
called and says can you come in tonight
if it's good for you you'll come in is
that correct um yeah if if I can I mean
I want to work as much as possible so
yeah one
more one more let go for it and and I
notice in in in the language in in the
bill it seem to cover situations where
if the boss needs you needs somebody
they can call you and they can't
penalize you if you can't make it in
that's that's a reasonable Choice isn't
you all right and seeing oh one more
question there you go just this is a
pretty straightforward question how many
hours a week you work um between 30 and
40 thank you okay thank you ladies I
appreciate you introducing the bill and
Carbono if you can state your name and
who you represent for the record
my name is Amy Sharbino I'm representing
Continental
Paving many of you have seen me
before okay um so I'm here to just we
oppose the bill for the strict reason
that uh overtime and inconsistent
schedules are what we live for um it's a
quite a different than the restaurant
market and the retail so for any that
don't we're a Paving Company um we
employ about 325 employees 98% of them
live in New Hampshire um so basically
from April to December that's our bread
and butter that's when we get most of
our work done um our industry as
construction as a whole is based on
trucks driving on the road large
Machinery making materials and the
weather so all of those things are
unpredictable and not able to be
scheduled 7 days out so having to make
this schedule and get it out to
employees would just it would actually
be detrimental to what we do on a daily
basis our employees we're just in a
different situation but I feel like this
would hurt us without intention of doing
so so I just wanted to bring that up um
whether you carve out construction or
something like that that's fine we don't
have anything against what they're
trying to do but as far as what it does
to our industry it I can speak for the
entire industry we've talked about it at
ACCC it would it would crush us um
schedules change on a daily basis as far
as when work's getting done the weather
changes on a daily basis a machine can
break and you can work longer than
you're supposed to just there are so
many moving parts literally in what we
do that it would be impossible and our
our people don't I can speak for them
they don't have a problem with what
we're doing we're not assigning on like
a they know they're coming in Monday
through Friday they just don't have like
exact hours that they're supposed to be
working that the schedule were supposed
to be posting for them so it's a totally
different animal but I do feel that one
thing would impact the other um and it
would impact us
negatively okay thank you for that
testimony representative
kill thank you for taking my question
yes uh yes so I understand the
volatility you know weather and all
these other things but and and I guess
we could try to carve out uh snow
plowing and and weather other related
things but isn't it also the case that
because your employees understand why
why you might cancel a day or why you're
starting this day instead of that day
that they're not likely to call the
labor department and file a complaint I
wouldn't disagree with you and you're
telling me that today but imagine my
business in 20 years when you're not
here to say this is how we interpreted
it I I feel like that you know I mean
like it's in writing and it's there
forever so it's not something just
because everybody here today says yeah
we think you're fine it doesn't mean
that it's not going to bite me down the
road kind that's that's what I that's
what I fear with legislation sometimes
it's the intent is I agree with you the
intent is not us but to be interpreted
in court One Day by the labor board but
but
basically yes so I just want to add that
the labor department U is compl
complaint based if nobody complains they
don't go and show up at your door and
say why aren't you why does you not work
today what's your C what's your schedule
if the law requires me to provide a
schedule seven days ahead of time there
will be somebody that will like it will
happen it's paperwork that we have to do
for but it's another person I would have
to employ to basically saying post this
and provide schedule s days ahead of
time I that's it's a person I would have
to employ as a company to be able to do
that to everybody to be able to post it
or email it to them whatever the things
were listed and at some point somebody
will somebody's wife somebody's
girlfriend will that's mad about being
fired or whatever will say oh they
didn't do this let's go back and get
them it's just a it's an unrelated you
can't have intent down the road as I
firmly believe that okay representative
Flanigan thank you Mr chairman and
actually I know your brother I think
better than your father possibly um I
race motorcycles oh Chad my cousin yes
oh your cousin sorry um there seems to
be an underlying on your testimony as it
relates to weather I mean you can have
equipment that's broken but you know
that stove could be broken too um do you
think uh if you took weather out of your
argument there that might have been e it
might be easier for you to to deal with
this this type of legislation so I think
if weather was an exception to the
schedule being incorrect I would still
based on the way it's written or the way
I understand it I would still have to
provide the schedule every week to 325
people and then the weather would only
have the ability to say oh the schedule
was wrong but I would still have to
provide that schedule which is what we
don't do now we and why do we need to do
that I guess would be my question that's
that's my objection to the whole thing
for followup sir just a quick one you
guys are busy we're busy like crazy so
so that means that if you're not at one
job you could be at another job correct
correct or if you finish one early you
may make it to job to and you may work
two hours later than your schedule said
but everybody wants to do that they want
their overtime right I'm just I guess
what I'm saying is I mean as far as
these guys are out running the Machinery
you know putting the asphalt down if
they're not on one job you can find
another job for them to work on they're
going to be working for you that week
right yeah but does it have to fit in
the schedule or if like you have a job
you were supposed to do on Tuesday and
it rains and then you want to do it on
Wednesday like Main Street in nsha so we
started that at 2 in the morning just
for traffic reasons right but it rains
on Tuesday so we push it to Wednesday
and you're like hey today tomorrow you
got to be here at 2:00 in the morning
our our guys are fine with that because
they know they were supposed to we tell
them it's coming up they know they're
supposed to do it but that's not what
the schedule was seven days ago it's
just this fluid system that's always
changing in general yes I could say all
my guys are working from 6:00 a. to 5:00
pm Monday through Friday but I you're
the way it's written I still have to
provide them with that written schedule
seven days ahead of time guessing what
hours they're working which 90% of the
time is going to be somehow
wrong it's providing all this paperwork
ahead of time like what is how that
would just be it's just another employee
it's more costs it's yeah well and
representative I'm sorry go represent
Flanigan no no I'm just I mean and and I
don't want to Discount the laborers okay
they do a vital job they do a great job
yeah but I'm just saying is if it's not
raining they're going to lay a pavement
down right that's what I'm trying to say
we're just working right exactly so so
you say to you say to your employee U Mr
Drago here you need to be here on this
week and work on this job but if you get
done early I want you over to the
nashille job because it's a bigger job
100% yes so other than the weather he's
going to be there for seven days or
whatever the number of days out on a
schedule yes but the the the start time
May waver by a half hour their end time
could waiver by one or two
hours all right represent
McKenzie thank you um coming in front of
the committee appreciate it and I
realized that you're Rough and Tumble
business bu uh but let me we heard
testimony earlier from uh from people
who are trying to manage their lives um
and I I think that's important um so how
do you accommodate that in uh in your
business when people need to take care
of children they need to go to medical
appointments and so is it is it so it's
your position that's untenable to give
people a schedule in your business is
untenable
so people don't have the space to be
able to do those kinds of things because
the schedule changes all the time is
that your position no I I most of the
time I'll have like just say for
instance a truck driver they come in
every single morning to my cousin and I
and one will be like hey tomorrow I have
a dock appointment at 9 o' we say okay
and they go they either come in later or
come in after or it's just easy we
manage it within our company very well I
not I don't think any of my employees
would say they can't do they don't take
vacation in the middle of the summer
sometimes because we're they get their
Winters off but I mean as far as making
a doctor's appointment or picking up a
sick kid or you know it's got to be
within the lines of what you actually
need to leave work for but I would say
all of them would say it's very possible
for a
followup but the idea that that somebody
doesn't know ahead of time yeah what
their schedule is going to be I mean I
couldn't work like that well my guys
know they're working Monday through
Friday from about 5 or 6: a.m. to about
4: to 6 7
p.m. you know and then when we switch to
nights for the do like you know we have
a whole list we tell them we we give a
form of a schedule to people but it's
not a written schedule every seven days
on repeat so basically our guys are on
repeat Monday through Friday unless we
tell them differently which we let them
know but we're still not emailing it to
them posting it like that that's my
issue with the whole thing is the amount
of it's clerical work and we're not
we're not solving any problems by doing
it I guess what I'm trying to
explain thank you okay uh represent
proud and then represent lab you still
have a question or you good okay um
thank you Mr chairman do you ever have
uh unusual seal changes for reasons
unrelated to weather maybe equipment
breaking down and you have to postpone a
job by a day or for example you know
supplies come in either earlier later
than expected or for example if you
mentioned D jobs um a tanker catches
fire on a highway you need to repave it
all of a sudden every day thank you
represent Library thank you for the
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um one thing
that really hasn't been touched on here
is is sickness and covid and could you
speak to how Co ripped through your
company and uh back in the day and and
forced you to have this massive Matrix
of scheduling and one had to cover
another shift and it was just I remember
talking Mark about this and it was
chaotic yeah and keeping people outside
and away from each other I mean just
Anything Could Happen where giving
somebody a schedule ahead of time but I
mean specifically Co we bought 20 more
trucks and put one less person in every
single truck I mean it's just scheduling
is that some people leave from home some
people come to the shop like we have so
many scenarios to reduce travel time get
people home quicker do all the things to
help like we believe in family so we try
not to work Saturdays we try not to work
Sundays that's like a policy like that's
what we live so we work long days Monday
through Friday so that our guys work
their butts off Monday through Friday
and then on Saturday Sunday they can
spend as much time with their family as
possible and sometimes we got to work a
Sunday night for the dot and that's fine
but our goal is for people to be with
their families we're we're very
amendable to what they possibly need so
now you're just you're basically making
it more rigid in my opinion and we don't
feel it's necessary in our specific
industry I'm not saying anybody else's
is not but in ours it would hurt more
than it would help okay and represent k
Mr chair and thank you again for taking
my question uh I did hear earlier that
you said that your people are working
all summer long and they take their then
take their vacations in the winter but
that's another bill uh but uh but I
agree with you this is not for your
industry correct and we should if we
carve this out and help the people who
are having the problem which is Mr
Summers industry we might be able to to
do find a way that that works for all
sides but I I agree that your your
company's doing fine and you know 5 days
a week over time doesn't matter what
time it is the roads get paved thank you
for Paving the roads and uh would you
believe I think we could find a way to
work make so that you're happy and
they're happy that that's all I ask
thank you unnecessary like we got to
keep our business running we're family
we compete with large corporations and
we got to keep it tight lean and mean
and adding unnecessary fixed cost is not
our goal all right thank you so much for
your testimony we appreciate it thank
please please stay your name and
affiliation for the
record good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is Mike Summers I'm the
president CEO of the New Hampshire logic
and Restaurant Association we're here
opposed to HP
487 um where to begin um so this
obviously our industry just for for a
little bit of clarity our our industry
obviously is an industry of flexibility
we have to be flexible the business
demands within our industry Change Daily
hourly um and so what we find is lot of
people come to our industry simply
because they can work fewer hours make
great money and still have that
flexibility of schedule and uh well I
certainly appreciate the uh the
frustrations voiced by in earlier
testimony I would also say that you know
when I worked in in those positions in
the industry you have to be an advocate
for yourself you have to request time
off in advance and I don't know about
you guys but I can't get a doctor's
appointment inside of three months
anyway um so I think it's a case of
being more proactive and making sure
you're requesting the time off in ADV
and I have yet to find a business in our
industry that doesn't have some sort of
a request time off process where people
can get the time off to go to doctor's
appointments get an oil change whatever
it might be so flexibility is incred
incredibly important to our industry I
would also say that our IND our business
um needs will change legitimately daily
hourly Etc and I take for a couple of
examples seasonally we have businesses
up in the north country that will have a
busload of tourists will show up on
their front door at 11:55 on a Thursday
unannounced no idea so they're working
the phones and they're finding people
Etc how do you schedule for that I I
don't I don't know that you can um you
know and and just in a local restaurant
I mean we pick up uh large parties and
those kinds of things on a regular basis
and so you can legitimately have
somebody call you the day before or two
days before with a party of 30 people
that's going to come in for a wake or
whatever it might be these kinds of
things again our industry is where
people celebrate and they commiserate
and uh they have all of those big life
experiences happen in our businesses and
frankly uh we have to be a flexible
industry in order to accommodate those
needs um one thing I would also point to
in the bill line 6A uh where it says
would not allow for a schedule it it
basically says that it has to be through
email or uh physically handed to them or
posted somewhere um most businesses that
I'm aware of now they don't even use
that it's an app you log into the app
and the app has your schedule on it and
you can switch shifts and you can do
whatever you want right in the app so if
this does move forward that I think
needs to be addressed because frankly
the industry is changing the way that it
it uh interacts with its
employees um but I think ultimately what
this does is it creates again more of a
burden on the business owners to to be
able to uh schedule this keep records of
those schedules um you know and other
things that I'm I'm not clear on in this
bill is if we have posted a schedule uh
what's the look back period when the
Department of Labor comes knocking on
our door because we have a disgruntled
employee that's filed a complaint for
something unrelated um these are the
things the gotcha moments that
businesses just cringe when we create
these kinds of pieces of legislation so
um I won't belabor the point but I will
I will with that I'll close and just ask
that you find this inexpedient to
legislate happy to try to answer any
questions all right turn thank you for
your testimony representative
avalani thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr Summers for being here uh lines 15
and
16 and I'll just relate it to the party
attorney that walks in with an hour's
notice um if you call an employee
to come in and they say no I don't have
to because I wasn't scheduled you have
no recourse against that
employee well sure but I mean let's face
it in today's uh hiring environment
you're not going to necessarily punish
an employee that can't make it in
because they have their child at home or
whatever reason that's not going to
happen um never has happened and I was
in the industry for years and years and
years so um I think it's a case of you
know as well as I do there's a tree you
just call everybody on the list until
you find the body that can come in but I
would I would say that that to my
knowledge it has never happened where
you would have some sort of retaliatory
action because somebody couldn't come in
with no notice I just I've never seen
that happened thank you you need the
staff more than you need to retaliate
okay repres K thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr Summers uh it seems to me
that there's some flexibility here in
lines
uh in lines uh 12 through 14 where if
something happens a party of thir 30
people show up you can call people on
that tree until you get somebody to come
in and and who's going to make some
money that day
uh and other than that if you know if
you think typically during this month of
August or that month of September you
have different ideas about your your
scheduling what you anticipate you would
hire the people that you need to staff
and let them know a week ahead and that
would probably work and then you have
the option to oops here's here's a bus
get get some people in is is that not
workable at
all frankly I don't think so because
you're requiring us to post the schedule
7 days in advance we may pick up the
party two days before the scheduled work
week that you posted the schedule May
start um so you know again some of our
business environment stuff happens
within 24 to 48 hours of when a schedule
would be posted so you know in a lot of
ways in many restaurants whilst they
post a schedule it's kind of a rolling
schedule the thing is continually
changing
follow up yeah yes sir for followup
thank you uh but again you schedule
would it be I don't know if it would be
easier if it was five days ahead of time
but the bill says seven but if you post
that schedule and then something happens
you can go to that the phone tree or or
your text text or app and you know
summon the people the ones who get there
first get the
money let me provide another example so
if you're in a diner situation right and
you're only open for breakfast 5 days
week and everybody in the Dina works
every one of those five days what is the
requirement to post a schedule everybody
everybody works
anyway um and you have a lot of
businesses that this is going to affect
because this affects everybody office
settings where somebody comes in at 9ine
and leaves at five now you are requiring
them to post that schedule for every
single
company one call yes please uh I don't
know if we could tailor this bill so it
aims at the the main target which is
appears to be the restaurant trade
there may be other there may be other
Industries where it is retail I'm not
sure uh but that would be I guess if we
were targeting this group in said you
know only this group whereas if we say
not the paving people but only the
restaurants it gets a little murky but
there's no one siiz fits all so we can't
do
anything if you want to carve out the
restaurants um you guys can restaurants
and hotels we're happy to work with you
I understand thank you
stop thank you I you know I think the
the issue is say somebody has
traditionally worked on Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday and then
suddenly the day before they're supposed
to work they find out that they have to
work on Monday because the schedule
changed and they don't have child care
or they had they were they were taking
their mother to the doctor or something
I think that's the issue that we're
trying to deal with here um that you
know if people have a regular schedule
then then that's one thing but you know
if somebody is
working has been working Tuesday um
Thursday and Friday and then suddenly
they find out that they're working
Monday and Wednesday and that messes up
all their child care do you have um an
idea of how that might be addressed for
the most part it's an open discussion
between the employer and the employee um
you know most people to your point most
people in our industry usually prefer to
have a set schedule and they may have
you know Tuesdays and Sundays off or
whatever it might be um but sometimes
those needs change but usually it's a
discussion between the employer and the
employee because the employer will then
approach an employee say look hey we
picked up a large party I need two
people that working can you be one of
the two people that is usually the way
it's handled that it's historically been
handled um again I'm not suggesting that
all operators operate that way but I
would suggest that the majority of them
operate operate that way but really I
think this bill does is now is inserting
the government in between the employer
employee relationship which for the most
part in our industry is a pretty
collaborative effort right we're trying
to serve our customers we're all trying
to make a little money and in many ways
restaurant employees act as kind of
independent contractors in a
way repr proud thank you Mr chairman
um if you if a restaurant say has two
employees one that pretty much always
says yes to a last minute shift request
and when a party of 5050 shows up
unexpected or something and another one
that always said almost always says no
do you think under this bill which
prohibits retaliation an employer would
have to be worried about the fact that
they always call the yes employee first
and get into that habit could be
considered retaliation against the no
employee where they might have said yes
that time and it's retaliation they
weren't asked I mean you could certainly
make that case yes but I think what you
would also find is that the employee
that always said yes made a heck of a
lot more money than the employee always
said no right and so but but the
employee who said no may have a very
legitimate reason may have child care
issues whatever it might be but again
that's where our industry has been an
industry of flexibility which is why
people work in our industry is for that
flexibility represent Castel
ring thank you Mr chair uh again going
with the portal looking at some of the
questions in there there was one about
predictive scheduling laws that happened
in other states I'm sure you're familiar
with them or heard of them could you
give us a little this essentially is a
predictive scheduling law yes okay I
also saw in the portal that six other
states have repealed those laws or made
laws to stop it from happening so I
guess because it was only specifically
the retail and restaurant industry so my
question to you is what do you think
that would change in New Hampshire by
this because like you said this is the
predictive scheduling you know law again
I think it becomes a huge issue
particularly for those service
Industries like the uh the restaurant
industry the hotel industry the retail
industry Etc because you're now another
requirement another gotcha moment um and
another reason for employees to create a
complaint with the Department of Labor
and so this just becomes much more of an
an antagonistic relationship between the
employee and employer which I think most
McKenzie when people come to work uh I
notice in many restaurants halfway
through the night they're
gone
so what's that practice what what do you
how does that work you love to ask me
the operational questions so I will say
that the way most restaurants work and
depending on size of operation time a
day that kind of thing but usually you
have an opening shift so say you have a
your total Flor coverage is eight
servers three or four of them would come
in in the first part of the shift they
do the opening side work they get
everything set up for everybody uh they
would work their shift and then when the
business starts to die off those four
would be the first four to leave because
they worked earlier hour or two whatever
it might be and then the the three or
four or five people that came in later
in the shift you know when it starts to
get busy they would be the ones that
would do the closing side work and they
would wrap up at the end of the day so
essentially you have this shift scenario
is how most restaurants approach
it for followup sir
so it's safe to say um uh that not only
is there no predictability in terms of
the schedule that they run but you know
the days of the week they work that they
actually don't have any
predictability uh in terms of how long
they'll work during the course of the
day because you have the right to send
them
home well but you have to understand you
know most restaurants you have a period
of time which is kind of your Peak
period right so if it's if it's for
dinner service it's usually probably
between 600 and 800 p.m. so that's when
we want to have all of the staff on the
floor but again I again I will speak for
as having been in these positions as a
server a bartender and others in in in a
past life that you can make an awful lot
of money in four or 5 hours um again it
just goes back to that's just kind of
how it works so that but again as the
business you're kind of essentially
trying to staff appropriately for the
business that you have I mean it would
make no sense to have everybody in the
business in the that works that day in
the establishment from you know 11: in
the morning until 11: at night just
would make no sense right because
between probably 2 and 5:30 in the in
the afternoon there's almost nothing
going on so that makes no sense and I I
think any industry would operate that
way all right seeing no further
questions thank you sir appreciate your
testimony thank you Miss Albert over to
you
Ma'am good afternoon my name is Daniel
Albert I'm the Deputy Commissioner of
the New Hampshire Department of Labor
thank you for having um me here today um
I'm here with attorney John garrian
general counsel to the department the
department has reviewed the language
proposed for House Bill uh 487 We
believe We Understand um its stated
intent and purpose as written we do
believe that we can administer it um as
written just sort of as a point of a
clarification and a technical suggestion
um and I believe this was raised uh by
some prior testimony currently the
requirements that are set forth uh as
written in the proposed language doesn't
specify or give provision relative to
how how long or even if an employer
should maintain records related to
notice um we would suggest perhaps
adding language requiring employers to
maintain those records um for some
period of time could mirror the language
that currently exists in
27549 which requires uh record
maintenance of other types for a period
of three years um for the purposes of
demonstrating compliance with the stated
requirements should uh the employer have
engagement with the Department in the
course of a labor audit or other contact
from an employee um would assist them in
demonstrating compliance with the stated
requirements um just a couple of other
points based off some of the other
testimony there had been some testimony
relative to various Industries the
department understands the language of
this bill to apply to all employers with
the exception of those that have fewer
than 15 employees in healthcare
Industries no other industry is carved
out so in the course of regulating it if
it were to pass as written um industry
specific uh Pro professions are not
would not be something that would be
taken into consideration the uh stated
standards would apply to all of them um
and clearly it only applies to hourly
employees it's not the scheduling
requirements as set forth would not
apply uh to salaried employees um just
by way of enforcement action were there
to be a violation found should this
language pass pass and the department
undertook a labor investigation what
would that potentially look like um a
violation of this nature uh should the
language pass would be subject to a
warning prior to penalty with the 30-day
period to cure and I am to take any
questions should the committee have any
sir uh I remember working on a a
legislation that dealt with the U 2hour
period that the employee has to be paid
if they're called into work so in the
case of the testimony you
heard what constitutes being called into
work that's an excellent question I you
know the way that the 2hour minimum
requirement works if an employ
is scheduled physically called um or is
coming to work at the request of the
employer they arrive and they are um
sent home uh bad bad weather tends to be
the example in this type of scenario um
but are otherwise told nope we don't
need you for quite that long they are
required with there are certain
exceptions certain industries are
accepted out from this um but they are
required to be paid that 2hour minimum
so if there were a posted schedule um as
required if this language were to pass
employee came in they arrived uh because
the schedule was posted and there's bad
weather or equipment was broken or
whatever the nature may be um would the
2hour minimum law still apply yes so
long as it's not one of those industries
that are Exempted out from the two uh
two-hour minimum
requirement for followup thank you and
the rate of pay in that case uh would
that be
um uh 2 32 327 an hour or would it be
the full minimum wage it would be the
rate of pay that the employee was hired
whatever stated that they agreed on at
the time of hire but they're not waiting
on tables at that point in the in the
terms of the service industry you mean
or like the food service industry or any
indust it would be at the minimum more
likely than not at the minimum wage rate
thank you right represent
Flanigan thank you Mr
chairman so the our employers here have
to keep those 7 Day lead slips for three
years for every employee is what you're
saying if this law passed the department
would recommend some some document um
retention provision to demonstrate
compliance with the stated requirement
we're simply noting that's currently not
outlined in there and we are envisioning
scenarios where we engage with an
employer um either based on a complaint
or in the course of a of an audit um and
issues related to scheduling came up um
in order to demonstrate to the
department it's a it's a it's a way to
assist Employers in demonstrating to the
department that they they've complied
with the stated requirements um you know
I don't know that it necessarily has to
be a copy of the actual schedule um or
some other documentation but some sort
of documentation retention um is is is
something worth considering for
compliance reasons so if I and I don't
want to put words in your mouth or the
Department of Labor um so you're you're
saying that if the employer shows a
consistent behavior in which you could
reflect that they've been doing this and
complying it could be like a quarterly
audit or something that they might do or
something that could prove to an
investigator that they are in compliance
that type of thing or something like
that more more likely than not and often
times when the Department's engaging
with an employer documentation to review
is a very helpful thing to have yeah um
so again we are anticipating you know
engaging with employers should the
requirement pass the question will be at
some point whether or not a particular
employer has complied with the stated
requirement and what best way for the
employer to demonstrate to the
department that they have done so if
there's complaint that they have not
thank you very much you're welcome
representa thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question so just a
clarifying question under the current
law is there any provision that allows
an employee that would be subjected to
bad standards or scheduling that they
could come and file a grievance or
something like that with the Department
of
Labor I may have you rephrase the
question or or let me make sure I
understood it correctly um are you
asking whether or not there's a
mechanism whereby an employee currently
aggrieved by scheduling practices can
complain to the department yes
correct not in the sense there's no
current requirement that an employer is
required to post like a weekly schedule
they are required to notify employees at
the time a hire about their rate of pay
the date and place um and time that date
and date and I think place that payment
is going to occur um and those types of
things um so there wouldn't currently
there's no provision similar to this
where if an employee came in and said oh
I I was scheduled you know 2 days in
advance and I was trying to take time
off could could the department um
investigate or or assist me with my
employer because I think a law has been
violated it would not be a law under our
jurisdiction for a followup so I'm sure
you get a lot of complaints but if
people complain of an issue like this
would there be a recourse not through
the Department of
Labor um I don't know if there's other
recourse in some other area um but not
currently through the laws that we
oversee represent proud thank you Mr
chairman
um so if this law were to pass and a
business that had you know not really a
you know weekly schedule published or
anything else but basically a standing
order that we work Monday through Friday
except holidays that are listed on our
website would that be enough to comply
with this law or would they have to
generate new paper work every week
that's an excellent question as written
the language is relative ly specific
that the employer is required to provide
this notice for its hourly employees um
of the work schedule at least seven days
in advance of any pay period um seven
days in advance certainly could be at a
point in time um it's the any pay period
provision it doesn't specify every pay
period uh so so possibly I that's one I
may want to contemplate um just a bit
and perhaps follow up with you on I
don't want to give poor guidance um I do
think as written there's an there it
could arguably con be construed that if
there is a set or static schedule you're
posting it 7 days in advance of any
specified pay period um if it changes uh
and I think that's encompassed within
provision two that's at 12 lines 12
through 14 if it's going to change due
to any sort of unforeseen circumstance
then there would have to be notice
provided as soon as possible I'll note
that language is specific to unforeseen
circumstances
um not specifically laid out in the
language itself but if there was a
planned change uh arguably you would
need to repost that notice within seven
days of advance of of the specified pay
period followup for follow-up sir um
again with this hypothetical company if
they sent a companywide notification hey
facility is closed next week because
we're having our air conditioner
replaced would that be enough if that
was a notice to all employees or would
they have to generate schedules times
however many the employees employes
employees they have specific to that pay
period to show hey this day is not in
our normal standing order because it's
not a holiday and it is a week day but
we're closed that
day that may depend on how the employer
um schedules their employees uh you
could send it to all employees it's a
singular notice if they all have the
same schedules if everybody's schedules
are different it may need to be more
individualized thank you all right
seeing no further oh now seeing one
further question
repres thank you Mr chairman I'll be
brief uh lines 15 and 16 I'll rephrase
that question uh for you um if a
employee would to call the department
and say my employer retaliated against
me I usually work three shifts I'm only
working two this week because I didn't
cover an ex shift last week would that
trigger an investigation by or an
inquiry by the Department of Labor it's
an excellent question it potentially
could um you know complaints when they
come in they are vetted um they're
there's conversation um with the
complainant again protected as it's an a
protected employee communication it
possibly could whether or not it would
rise to the level of a violation um of
this provision were it to pass would be
very fact specific and dependent upon
what was borne out with engagement on
the employer but it potentially could R
you know initiate um interaction with
the department or a labor audit follow
for followup sir would that preclude the
employer from having any other things
looked at while you're there invest
tigating this yeah that's an excellent
question so there is a provision in 273
I think it's provision 9A 9 or 9A uh
that details um uh sort of the scope
that the Department is supposed to look
at we do abide by those requirements um
so you know would it be uh the do is
completely
open operating within the confines of
those of of the scope requirements um
the department would do so so um it not
to say that in the course of engaging
with the employer if other information
were provided indicative that there may
be other issues that that would not also
be looked at that could be a possibility
um but it is not uh it would not um
investigations are not approached on a
looking for all things uh manner um in
in accordance with that statutory
provision thank you than chairman all
right thank you ma'am I appreciate your
testimony and
uh seeing no further pay cards
and no further comments and questions I
closed the hearing on HB
487 and I open the hearing on HB
379 and representative kahill I think
out represent labr could you see if
879 no
that's
e
good afternoon sir are you here for uh
so for the record we're opening the
hearing on HB 379 relative to youth
employment during the school year and at
night and representative kill uh it's
your bill and you're introducing it
welcome thank you very much Mr chair yes
I am representative Michael kahill from
New Market I represent the towns of New
Market and newfields and Rockingham 10
and 379 addresses uh youth employment
during the school year and at night uh
in the past we had legislation that
covered these topics and uh in a a bit
of a frenzy I believe part A B an
important section was was
repealed and so what I would like to do
with this bill
is uh first of all if you if you're
reading the bill you'll see that uh
we're I've made note of the fact that um
it used to say between June 1 and Labor
Day where to that effect and yeah June
one in Labor Day and schools don't work
that way in New Hampshire anymore uh
your kids are often going back uh the
last week of August and they leave
school sometime in June uh 15th 21st it
depends on snow days and other things so
it's really when the school begins and
when the school ends that's the time
we're talking about that I think that
young people 16 to 17 should be wrapping
it up at
9:00 and going home and if they haven't
got their homework done yet getting to
their homework getting a good night's
sleep getting in that bus at 6 o' in the
morning and getting their education so
they can be prepared for what lies ahead
of them uh certainly summer jobs are
great they can work lots of hours in the
summer working after school job I think
we've probably done that it's good
experience you get a little a little
money in your pocket a little practice
handling money and you get work
experience but you know too much of a
good thing uh can be can affect you
affect your school performance affect
lots of things and uh that's why I
brought this bill forward and some of
felt that the restrictions were too
burdensome on the employer and I I I
have some of the copies waiting but this
this folder
this is uh youth labor
violations and it's not because the the
laws are too burdens them are too
difficult it's because of the
impunity that employers look at them
with and they say well I did it I I had
51 ver 51 VI of this kind of violation
from the same employer the inspection
reports and it doesn't matter because
you know it's a cost of doing business
and the other part of this that I I find
troubling is that the violations you you
know the the fines are vastly
discounted so where it should be you
know uh
$5,100 um brought down to $600 now maybe
they have the best lawyer working this
or maybe the department is really just
trying to go out of the way not to be
too hard on businesses but that's quite
a discount so I I'm not going to go into
uh that we should probably not discount
the fines much I'd like to reduce the
violations I think the way the way to
reduce the violations is not to get rid
of the law but to educate and motivate
the employers to follow the law and
there was law protecting you know 16 to
17 year olds who probably need
protection from themselves because if
you remember you might not have been
that smart when you were that age you
might have done things that you might
might not do now even if you could and
uh so we we need to be thinking about
this education is important yesterday
you may be aware that there was a
hearing in rep's Hall I think it was 7
hours of people that that came to
testify the about the importance of
education and a rich and well-rounded
education at that and if you want to
have your kids uh playing sports uh
maybe uh music uh on the com on the
robotics team and meeting all their you
know their other core subjects I think
they need to have a good night's sleep
they need to be not wor worried about oh
you know if I can I get another shift in
so I can uh have that money for that car
they they really need to be focusing on
their education whether they're going to
college or not high school is is a
minimum it's a minimum and and uh we
need to be able to have those kids at
their at the job when it's you know when
it's at the appropriate time in bed or
doing their homework at school it's all
about balance so that's my testimony
and I think that I've spoken to a number
of parents of teenage kids and they they
wouldn't want their kids working past
9:00 they think it's outrageous and yet
sometimes the employer will say well you
know can you work can you work till 10:
can you work till 11: and if the answer
is no well next kid and we don't want to
deny somebody an opportunity to work and
get that experience just because their
parents are trying to take to look out
for them so this isn't so much about
parents' rights this is about the kids
rights and the employer right the
employer should be able to have the kid
you know there and working their shift
leaving coming back and maybe they come
back next summer because they liked it
so much and they and the school work was
up and there's no conflict and uh this
is the way it should be working I think
9:00 is late enough uh on a school night
and 11:00 on the weekend no problem
summertime not s out but we should we
should reinstate this and uh pass this
law okay thank you for introducing this
piece of legislation if we can have
representative
ly thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question does this pertain to
a certain sector in the economy is this
restaurant is this uh any any because
these violations are there are in
addition to restaurants and fast food
there are municipalities
golf courses so
it's any once this is I'm afraid to say
it one size fits all but you got you got
you got your teenagers you want them to
work let's have a
balance okay thank
PR thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for my question um regarding section two
uh does it apply and notice it says days
the week fairly statically uh how does
this work if there's a holiday if
there's a Monday holiday if there's a
Friday holiday in the week I mean it
seems like that would be a little bit uh
heavy-handed and and not quite with the
intent of the of the section uh if it
applies equally to
holidays right
um that's that's an interesting point
representative and I know that there was
an effort previously to include that you
know if if there's a Monday the teachers
uh work session and why can't they do
this that's a little bit hard to to to
follow because you know you might have
kids from three different high schools
and working in your business
a
holiday for a holiday you might have a
point and I think that's a reasonable
Amendment provided that you'll go along
with the rest of the bill follow for
followup Mr uh again regarding the same
section does it apply equally to
in-person work and Tork I'm I'm thinking
back to my job when I was 16-year- old
was a computer programmer and uh if if I
was doing that now I would think a lot
of it would be over zoom and Tork and
not necessarily in person work like it
was back then uh uh thank you for the
question I I think it should apply
because you're working uh hopefully
getting paid I I'm not sure
how uh again labor law is the labor law
is um they respond to
complaints and I don't know where the
complaint would originate and you know
I'd like to think that your older self
would be telling you younger self you
maybe this is too much and I should get
some sleep and and all that but I'm not
sure that would happen and so uh again
that that some of those people who are
programming into the night uh whether
they're going to get into that school uh
with their grades are suffering or not
I'm not sure but they're certainly
getting programming experience thank you
okay thank you and representative
Flanigan and then representative
oh thank you thank you Mr chairman uh so
that means if someone's 14 or 15 they
can work unlimited hours no federal law
prohibits
that federal law at at least for now I I
Market Basket has some young people
working for him and I think they
advertise for 14 year olds but it's very
it's very it's limited by federal law
okay
chairman I'm sorry one one discussion at
a time and Miss Albert if we can confirm
that can you just confirm that that that
that's true
um restrictions and as well as there are
our restrictions and time liit
lawal restri state law specifically
address sorry time time restri so our
state law specify under 16
through olds uh cannot work Beyond
900m uh
put okay thank you appreciate that
clarification representative Wen all
right thank you Mr chairman
representative kill yes if I can direct
your attention to the final section of
the bill lines 14- 16 14 through 16 they
state during the months in which school
is in session no youth shall be
permitted to work later than 9:00
p.m. as you stated earlier uh schools
now many schools will extend the school
year will extend into early June and
some will start in late August
so by the Plain reading of this would
that mean that no student could work
past
9:00 uh in early August or in late June
because those are in fact months in
which school is in
session uh no because
the months during the time during
between the date on which school year
begins and the date the school year ends
that's that's what we're really speaking
about if if I need to fix that line I'd
be happy to do so
followup for followup sir
I this new section
that I'm talking about and asking about
says in addition to the provisions of
27684 so it seems like this would be
even more restrictive than uh your
earlier uh earlier notation in the bill
that the school year begins when it
begins it
ends
well again the the intent is to is to
have the 900
pm and the 11: PM apply during the
school
year um and if that's on if that needs
to be changed I'd be happy to do that so
that instead of during the months when
school is in the session during the
aforementioned school year that would be
okay represent
sylvestro thank you thank you for taking
my question uh representative line uh 15
if this was mentioned before I'm sorry
if I didn't catch it uh you have working
no later than 900m on Sunday through
Thursday but if it were a Monday holiday
would they not be able to
work that what you just CL I apologize
that sounds like the proud
then okay I just want to be sure I
wasn't misunderstanding okay very good
okay representative Prout do you have a
followup um follow up to a different
conversation
actually um I'm noticing that a
difference between the text in section
one section two whereas in section one
it only applies to uh youths that are
duly enrolled in school whereas section
two doesn't have that limitation so if a
a 16 or 17 1-year-old is no longer ruled
in school perhaps because they have
graduated and they're still
17 um they would still be subject to
these
restrictions uh another wonderful catch
representative proud and uh we could
readily fix that thank
you represent
nalani thank you Mr chairman
um you held up violations are those
violations since we changed the law or
are those overall violations over a
different period those are older
how old um a few years a few years yeah
back when the before the law was changed
thank you follow they're not all they're
not all this night work follow up Mr
chairman yes for a followup how do you
square away the school year begins and
the date the school year ends or the
school school year ends and the date on
which It Begins for the following school
year if they are going to school out of
state because we we have people that
immigrate in immigrate out for school
right um well I think what what happened
now if you have if you have a business
and you have high school kids maybe
they're coming from two different
schools and you know not too far away
you would uh take a look at the
calendars and know when the school
starts and when the school begins and
furthermore you would know when holidays
they take and when their week-long
vacation occurs which I know they're
looking forward to one coming up later
this month in many cases I would imagine
that if you had somebody crossing the
border uh from Vermont or or or or
Massachusetts they're willing to take a
lower wage um you could also do the same
diligence to make sure that they were
out of school and not playing
hookie follow for followup sir so how
would a uh employer um somebody turns
them in saying they had a high school
kid working during the week when
everybody else was in school and do
shows up to their door and says how come
this person was here last week would you
expect more violations or less
violations
uh I would expect less violations and I
would expect that uh do isn't going to
show up at your door I think they would
at least give you a call first and
perhaps ask you a question uh I don't
know that they would just show up and
let's see your payroll records and
looking for this kid from uh Albuquerque
I don't know thank you and one final
followup Mr chairman yes sir um setting
a standard for 9:00 p.m. and 11:00 p.m.
if a child if a student was to sign up
with to punch out at 9005 that would
trigger a violation for the
do uh I suppose that is technically
correct but um I I would I would be
surprised if that was meriting an
enforceable an enforced violation and
especially if it wasn't uh you know
frequent and five minutes is is minimal
I think there I think there's probably a
threshold this will be a final one Mr
chairman is this your third final one
third final one all right okay I just
check somebody to use the
uh uh reference to Market Basket many
employees and if there was a line at the
punch out machine and everybody all of a
sudden you're 10 back 10 12 Back and
You're punching out 9006 9007 9008 right
it would trigger if the if the do was in
there doing a records check on youth
employment it would trigger violations
it's interesting that you bring up
Market Basket uh but let me let me if
you have a line of people all punching
out 9006 9007 I I think that offers a
plausible explanation that they were and
they were completed their work and
merely trying to do the accounting so
that they would be paid appropriately
and God forbid not have any overtime but
You' mentioned Market Basket and you
will remember the former Deputy
Commissioner uh Rudy Ogden who said to
me you know that looking at all these
other places with multiple violations
Market Basket doesn't have any Market
Basket pays attention to it and I don't
hard okay thank you Mr chairman no more
followups no good R schz thank you Mr
chair I don't know if you can answer
this and I don't know if our friends
from the do are going to speak but do
you know if there's any need for um
underage kids who are in school and it's
the school year do their parents have to
give permission and is the school
involved in any way in um making
sure uh do they have any involvement I
guess is really my question that's so
that's a very good question I know at a
certain age work papers are required and
that's one of the violations in this
folder uh but I don't know what I don't
know off hand what the but I'm pretty
confident that the labor department does
know and um and I don't I don't know
that parental consent is part of it we
can we can ask that when they testify
for a
followup relatedly but if this is not
the current law would you be open
amendable to that as an amendment to
your bill to require parental um
permission or andoor School permission
um I would not be opposed to that in a
Schultz
Amendment all right seeing one more
question sir thank you Mr chairman in
the first section lines 2 through five
you're adding language it
um
basically they cannot work in a week
other than the school's vacation
week and is your intention that the
because it says school's vacation week
singularly is that the spring break week
and as a followup to that would that
preclude them from working during
Christmas break which may even be longer
than a week in their school for exam
example if a student uh Works selling
Christmas trees at the corner lot then
he would not be allowed to under this
language with your change is that
correct do I have that correct I I uh my
interpretation is when the school is on
vacation I believe they have two uh two
weeks uh February and April uh then the
kid would work as if it were summer they
would not have the 9 or the 11:00
restrictions
okay so instead of
the school's vacation week it should be
a school's vacation weeks right or
school okay school vacation weeks either
way
plural all right uh represent Prout
thank you Mr chairman um again regarding
section two for night workk it says
after 9:00 p.m. and 11:00 p.m. but it
doesn't say until when can kids clock in
at 12:01 a.m. and work all through the
midnight shift or or what is the intent
there uh that would not be the intent
um I'm assuming that they're getting out
of school at around
3:00 and if this if the business is next
door that would be four o'l maybe if
they had a little snack for dinner uh
five hours wouldn't be too
bad uh for them to
work I mean they're allowed 35 hours so
5 hours every day after school would be
no sorry following up because I I think
you misunderstood the question perhaps
they did um it says they can't work
later than 11:00 p.m. for example on a
week weekend but could they clock in
just after midnight and work till 5 or
600 in the morning or for example if
they're a farmand and you know they have
to get up and milk the cows at say 4:00
a.m. or 3:30 a.m. and that's when they
would clock in is that allowed I mean
what's it says after 11:00 p.m. but it
doesn't say until when and what is the
what is the intent there um I I believe
there are other restrictions about the
hours the the beginning hours it can't
be before 6: a.m. as as I recall but I
did not change that or put that into the
into this language uh that's another
thing to look at but I don't I don't
anticipate many
businesses starting starting someone Shi
to 12 1201
and having them go until 9 that evening
thank you all right sir thank you for
introducing the Bill thank you for your
testimony and I'd like now i' like to
night good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record Mike
Summers president CEO the New Hampshire
LOD lodging and Restaurant Association
excited to be with you again um uh again
another bill that seems to be targeted
squar restaurants so that's exciting um
couple of things I would say that uh
representative kahill's um efforts
around the language around uh changing
you know the schools start of the school
year end of the school year that kind of
thing we kind of in two minds about it
um ultimately I I guess we could live
with those changes if we if we if we had
to I think where we're really concerned
more than anything is the reintroduction
of night work um frankly it's only been
a year or two since we took night night
work away and I think uh part of the
reason for that was it was uh incredibly
hard for businesses to manage now
frankly the way it was written before
was even worse um so I will concede that
point but um part of the part of the
reasons for the effort when it when it
uh when we eliminated night work was
simply because this really aligns state
with federal law and the biggest problem
for businesses in New Hampshire is that
we have two standards on many things
particularly in the wage and our space
so for example you'll have situations
where uh 16 and 17 year olds can't work
past 9:00 in New Hampshire assuming this
passes but under federal law there's no
restriction on that so you would have a
scenario where the US Department of
Labor may do an audit and say yeah sure
let them work whatever they want to work
and then the New Hampshire Department
Labor comes in under a complaint and now
we have you know 15 different violations
so that that uh disparity between state
and federal is what creates the biggest
headaches for small businesses
particularly so reintroducing this I
think creates a lot of problems for our
business owners and I I appreciate the
argument that you know students should
be focusing on their their education Etc
but you know my son when he played
soccer in high school I mean he was at
practice till 11 o'clock at night you
know three nights a week five five
nights a week when they were in season
so I don't really buy the difference
between working and you know learning a
skill in a career and trade and life
skills versus you know playing soccer or
some other sport
um and and I I guess uh the biggest
issue one of the big issues is uh
getting teenagers to do the things you
need them to do is a challenge and for
those of you who have kids I'm not
telling you anything you don't already
know but to get them to clock out at
9:00 or before is is a is usually a
problem um so and to representative
Alan's point about you know there's a
line of kids trying to clock out 9 and
you have 9056 7 89 yes those would all
be uh violations and yes they would
stack and yes uh those would be issued
so um so I think those are my my big uh
big concerns and with that I'm happy to
try to answer any questions oh I guess
the one last thing I would say is there
was a comment made that if an uh 16 or
17 year old was told that we need you to
work till 10 and they refuse to and then
they get fired there is not a business
on in the state of New Hampshire right
now is going to fire a teenager because
we can't replace them
so uh there's a lot of flexibility there
and parents and their Stu their children
have an awful lot of Rights uh and and
Power in that discussion so thank you
all right reprid Warden thank you in
your in your experience is it is it
common where there are some students who
want to work extra hours because they're
saving up for example for college
expensive or buy a new car and they
would like the opportunity to work
Beyond nine o'clock yes we've certainly
seen that and we've also seen some
instances where uh a student is only
working the minimum possible hours and
they're only doing it because their
parents are making them do it you know
life skills and those kinds of things uh
less and less more these days but yes
we've certainly seen
that Ram labry thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question uh what
percentage would you say make up the
workforce of 16 and 17 year olds in the
restaurant and hotel industry what what
percentage is out there the reason I ask
is because they're for my industry um
they're almost as elusive as perhaps a a
kangaroo pelt
appreciate that question um so I will
say that U they're not a huge portion of
our Workforce um but that certainly a
critical part of our Workforce because
they're the ones that would be busing
tables running food doing those kind of
you know hostessing they're the kind of
the part-time positions that are only
for a few hours in the course of a shift
those kinds of things but they're
certainly not the backbone of our of our
Workforce
represent thank you Mr chairman good to
see you again Mr Summers um look a
couple years ago we also rolled hold
back the ability for 16 year 16 and 17
year olds to bus tables that had alcohol
on them correct um we also remove the
time limit because some places are open
till 10:00 and owners would have to
schedule two different people um could
you speak to that and how that would
affect if this bill passed yeah so
frankly I think the as I mentioned
earlier the biggest challenge was that
misalignment between state and federal
because now you have a situation where
you would literally have to send some of
your staff home at you know 9:00 um and
you may to your point be open till 9:30
or 10 and and you know clean up whatever
it might be but we certain and and we
they repealed the restriction on um you
know 16 17 year olds working in the
lounge setting uh because frankly it was
an Antiquated law and it really had no
place um didn't make any sense uh but uh
obviously you know these guys the 16 17
year olds are critical to our industry
they're critical to the grocery store
industry to the retail industry
um but you know
again it's
exciting thank you thank you Mr chairman
all right represent McKenzie thank you
uh you would know more about this
tonight because I didn't spend a whole
lot of time in youth employment but
could you speak into the mic please I'm
sorry about
that so the uh the federal had the
federal laws are in place as well so are
you suggesting that this conflicts with
the federal laws that that the federal
laws are more lenient than would be be
the uh the state laws yes so for 16 and
17 year olds there are no real
restrictions on on youth uh employment
uh 14 and 15 they certainly are and your
question earlier and I think Department
of label will answer this question but
uh 14 13 14 15 rols they can't work past
pm thank
you all right see no further questions
oh representive C go ahead just uh thank
you Mr chair I got a question when it
comes to industry this bill itself what
specifically would it affect or how
would it affect restaurants and
businesses do you think
negatively so it just creates another
regulatory burden for the businesses uh
more than likely it's going to lead to
more uh penalties and fees Department of
Labor uh because again I think the
biggest challenge we had with like a
9:00 p.m. or whatever the the time cut
off was the issue was we could never get
people to clock out on time and not for
want of trying um it's a case of you
know go clock out at 9:45 and at 10:15
they're still walking around talking to
their friends so it is what it is it's
the the teenage experience but that
frankly has been the huge biggest hurdle
for our industry um is getting them to
actually clock out on time so that we're
not facing penalties fees fines
Etc all right great thank you sir
afternoon Miss
good afternoon my name is Danielle
Albert I'm the Deputy Commissioner of
the New Hampshire Department of Labor
thank you for having me here today um
I'm here with Attorney John garrian
General councel to the department um the
department has reviewed the language uh
that is proposed in House Bill 379 We
believe We Understand its um intent and
its purpose to kind of start by
addressing the night work provision and
some of the questions that have been
raised around state requirements as they
exist currently and federal law
requirements as they exist um currently
uh both the state law and the federal
law so New Hampshire's law and the fsla
both address um our uh timing
requirements I.E how early or how late a
youth who's under the age of 16 can work
so you're 14 15 year olds um 13 year
olds under current iteration of state
law and you can find the provision at
RSA 276
A4 um youth who are under the 16 years
of age can't work earlier than 700 a.m.
and no later than 900 p.m. when we look
at the federal side what the fsla
requires um youth of that age can start
no no earlier than 7 a.m. and no later
than 7 p.m. except in summer when it it
rises up to 900 p.m. so um by way of the
questions that were raised relative to
if this provision um creating 276 a13a
regarding Night War were to go into
effect would that um not line up
perfectly or exactly with how fsla
treats it I think that that is accurate
under this proposed language youth would
um not be permitted to work later than
900 p.m. Sunday through Thursday but
that time then goes up to 11:00 p.m. on
Friday and Saturday employers who were
subject to the fsla and state law would
need to be mindful of both requirements
um just for a point of context of
understanding while the depart if if
this were to pass and if a youth of that
age were working up to 10: p.m. may not
rise to the level of a violation under
the state requirement it may be a
different story under the federal
requirement so um point I am trying to
highlight is the employers would have to
be mindful of both requirements even
though the state's not regulating the
federal law that would come from us do
um as a technical Point um in the
language that's proposed for night workk
it does reference specifically that no
youth shall be permitted to work within
um later than the prescribed hours no
youth as the department understands it
encompasses youth um inclusive of um 16
17 15 14 13 there are our prescriptions
at
276a um that differ for the Youth who
are under 16 from what this night work
provision is putting forward so if the
intent is for the um night work Bill to
address just those 16 and 17 year olds
there may be benefit to specifying as
such otherwise there could be a
potential conflict with the hour
restrictions for under 16s that
currently exist at section 4 um again
the the under 16s are uh limited to um
currently working no later than 900 p.m.
this now authorizes two days a week when
they could work until 11:00 p.m. and
those two May conflict with one another
if they both go into effect without
change um as it relates to the first
provision uh uh amending the language uh
regarding the number of hours that can
be worked for 16 and 17 year olds when
school is in session um those particular
sections appear to be removing the
language relative to predetermined work
week in which school is in session um
for 5 days it is now more broadly
referencing the date between when the
school year begins and the date when the
school year ends the department
understand what that means although we
would note um it's not so clear what
week is being uh being referenced by the
statute is it the employer's
predetermined work week or that week
schedule is it a more commonly
understood Monday through Sunday type of
week um so some clarification in that
regard may be of benefit we potentially
could foresee um maybe inconsistent
understanding from employers on applying
uh what week means when determining
whether or not youth in that particular
age category are going um you know above
or staying within the 35-hour uh limit
that's prescribed um and we are happy to
take any questions if there may be any
representative proud thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um under the federal or state
law for the 13 to 15 year olds are there
any industry specific carve outs on the
hours like for example in
agriculture that's an excellent question
I would need to go I would potentially
need to research under the fsla um there
are certain exemptions uh for youth
labor more so in like the Hazardous
occupations context for agricultural um
and my vague recollection is there may
be some um our restrict something more
formal together check the laws and make
certain that the answer I'm giving is
accurate is it okay if I follow up with
you on that absolutely thank you yeah
thank you representative lry thank you
Mr chair um thank you for taking my
question in the case of a violation
which polls rank NHD or federal do do do
that's an excellent question and I I
don't really know that it's a um an
issue of who pulls rank uh there can be
circumstances where violations occur
both at the state and the federal level
and there's involvement from State
Department of Labor and US Department of
Labor um efforts are made to not you
know duplicate I.E um if wages are being
adjusted both agencies are not going to
adjust wages but you could arguably have
a scenario where um youth hour um
prohibitions under state law are
violated State Department of Labor is
involved a violation is cited uh US
Department of Labor has gone in they
find violations under the federal law
and also site under their laws
violations how us do approaches
investigations or how they determine
their violations I I I can't speak to
since I'm not part of that federal
system um but you could arguably have
situations where there's um where both
both agencies could cite violations okay
follow up I think you just answered it
um from a guidance perspective who you
know if was one is 700 p.m. and one is
9:00
p.m. where do we as business owner yeah
who do we listen to and I've got caught
up in this before where it's it's who
who pulls rank yeah no that's a that is
also a really excellent question so you
know us do puts out guidance and again I
won't I won't speak for them or as to
where their guidance come from they
generally guide um you know abide by the
more restrictive of the two requirements
because then you're in compliance with
both um so you know in a situation such
as um this proposed language If This
Were to go into effect you um dep the
New Hampshire Department of Labor would
not have concern about violation with a
youth who's 16 working uh or a youth
who's 15 working until 11 on a Friday
because it's authorized by state law USD
may take exception to that because their
requirement is you can't work past seven
or nine depending where in the year you
are and you and that employer then may
be um dealing with violations uh at the
federal level through the US do if you
comply with the more restrictive of the
two arguably you're keeping yourself in
compliance with both you're welcome and
represent Schultz thank you Mr chair and
um forgive me my views on this have
changed dramatically since I was this
age and now I'm 54 so forgive me that I
do not know this um do are is there any
arrangement for parents to give
permission and to what degree does that
factor in yes so under current state law
there are certain types of permissions
dependent upon age category again we
look at the 16 uh under 16 and then 16
to 17 year olds there are certificates
that um parents Andor school districts
um can have to complete when youth are
working uh and then or the or the
parental permissions so there is a there
are um Provisions in place that address
uh that type of a
parental permission and in some times
it's School District permission as well
again dependent upon what age category
you're in I'll just briefly add to that
the the permissions relate to the
overall employment they don't relate to
there's no um permissions for specific
work hours or to work in excess of those
hours it's just about can can the youth
work in this particular place or not
thank you for the clarification and if
you could fill out a pink card before
you go that' be great rosett proud uh
thank you Mr chairman um so I represent
Hudson the board town with m Metts um If
an employer has two locations one in
Mass one in New Hampshire um could a
youth have different rules depending on
which location they're scheduled to work
at uh how would that work would it be
the employment relationship where
whichever location they're hired would
it depend on their schedule which rules
apply can you clarify any of that at all
I I can try I believe what you're asking
is um If an employer has a location in
New Hampshire and then another one in
another State's
jurisdiction um are you asking if the
youth employ employees working at both
locations what does the employer have to
do yes essentially if the employee has
sometimes picks up is assigned a shift
of the New Hampshire location sometimes
signed a shift to the Massachusetts
location does the rules follow the
employment relationship does it follow
the schedule of location how does that
work yeah that's a very good question so
um New Hampshire's jurisdiction would
track to the work that's being performed
in New Hampshire um more likely than not
and I'm not familiar with their
requirements
Massachusetts requirements would track
to the employment that's being um uh
that's being undone in
Massachusetts thank you all represent
McKenzie thank you uh Mr
chair a couple of things were uh that
were raised during the hearing the first
thing is as it relates to this kind of
drift that people supposed to end
certain time and they kind of drift off
uh so that that would be the first and
then is it the if I could just roll it
together if if the um is is it the
position of the do that you're worried
about 2 or 3 minutes or 5 minutes is
that do you generally uh get aggressive
when it comes to that that kind of
performance yeah I um if I understand
the question you're asking how does the
department view scenarios where um a
youth has worked a couple of minutes up
up to maybe five if I understood
correctly beyond the prescribed time
frames by Statute um it really does
depend and I I it's a very fact
dependent inquiry so you know I think
the department is generally pretty good
about um you know one engaging with
employers if it is a time or two there's
no real pattern or practice of it um
it's something we may engage on it may
not necessarily um rise to the level or
get cited as a super you know as a heavy
civil um penalty you know violation if
there's a pattern in a practice of it if
there's been a lot of complaints related
to it um it would depend on a whole host
of different facts and circumstances
attendant to that uh situation
for the Department to determine whether
or not you know five minutes is rising
to the level of something that we are
concerned about concerned about you know
for um more more um stronger more
strenuous uh perhaps enforcement
actions okay thank you so much
representative thank you Mr chairman
um the school
year um if a 16 or 17 only has one class
given that there's a lot of you know
schedule Shifting the front load you
know freshman J you guys get it um would
the employee be penalized for having
them work that's a very good question so
the language relative to when school and
in session has been struck and the
language as draft is talking about the
date on which the school year begins and
the date in which the school year ends
it does make notation um for other than
a week you know the school's vacation
week um but arguably it could be
interpreted that if you're between that
start and that end date you've got to
abide by uh the requirements as set
forth in the the 35h hour um requirement
provision as set forth in that language
follow Mr chairman yes sir how would you
how would that transfer over to a
private or or a charter school if they
have a differing school vacation weeks
it would be contingent upon one I
believe the owners would be on the
employer to assure that they are
grabbing or take U accessing or finding
asking for the relevant schools calendar
or sessions whether that's access I know
a lot of them are accessible online I
don't know about private or Charter
Schools how they post those things um
there would be an onus I believe on the
employer to obtain that and then to
assure that they have an understanding
of it so that they're being mindful that
the 35 hours within that time frame or
48 if it's during the summertime um is
is being abided by and then FAL followup
Mr chairman yep how would you deal with
this with homeschoolers
excellent question so with homeschoolers
it would very much be um the same the
employer you know should arguably check
with the homeschooled student Andor
their parents are usually the ones
administering a homeschool program when
is your school year starting and ending
um in you know in general in the
department has testified to this effect
in the past if the employer doesn't have
that information or it's not accessible
uh we do turn an eye towards the
calendar of the school district where
the youth is
domiciled and represent
proud thank
you uh thank you Mr chairman um so just
following up on that and clarifying when
this refers to the school year in this
bill it's the school year specifically
the youth employee not necessarily the
school year of the public school
district or or anything else it's it can
be a specific to each individual
employee evaluation that's that's how
the department understands the language
um again if Hudson School District
starts on August 15th and ends because
of snow days that they called on um June
22nd that would be the start and end of
the school year if you've got another
student who were who goes to conquered
and conquered started on the same day
but ended earlier because they had less
snow days that their start and their end
dates would be different thank
you represent aani thank you Mr chairman
if you are 16 or 17 and you're a junior
or senior and you are out on um a work
program sometimes in a trade school
you'll class one week how would that
square with working more than 35 hours
in the week that you're in technically
shop that's an excellent question when
you reference excuse me work program do
you mean the approved um Educational
Learning opportunity programs um those
are approved through the
department um
I might want to go back and make sure
that I look at the language in
27922 AA to make certain that I'm not
missing anything um I think the hour
requirements could still arguably apply
U the 35 hours um the 35 hours that are
referenced in that Pro the provision
Roman numeral VI um but if that is okay
I wouldn't mind looking at the language
in 279 just to assure I'm not missing
anything and and providing a written
followup if that's okay with you and and
follow with chairman yes and also the
next section as well if they're limited
to that 9:00 p.m. and or 11:00 p.m. yes
um cuz I know our industry typically
runs later during the holidays and other
Industries might run earlier but my
might expect them to work more than 40
hours per week
sure thank you thank you Mr all right
thank you so much for your testimony
it seeing no further pin cards no
further
questions I close the hearing on HB 379
and open the hearing on HB 757 relative
to tip pooling and sharing and automatic
service
charges and uh representative kale
you're presenting this
bill all right we look forward to
it and just for everyone's edic
edification we've got 52 minutes in this
room and then we're pumpkins and so if
we could uh work our questions
appropriately
thank you Mr chair uh I remain Michael
kahill from Rockingham 10 new market and
new
757 I believe I'm although I've I've
handled out handed out a bunch of copies
I'm I'm missing I'm missing one more
document which is key to this it's the
it's the U document that I I prepared uh
I found on the internet about how one
goes
about uh with tip sharing and tip
pooling ways that it is done as no
that's not it that's an article about
the law that was changed and how that's
the other situation so I I apologize if
I I will find it an email to you but it
explains is it sort of a guide of how
you might explain in your restaurant we
we do tip pooling this way that way
these are the percentag as a guideline
which I provided during the testimony on
uh S sp269 A couple of years ago and as
I
recall uh Mr Summers said this is this
is great this is a good document this is
this is what our attorneys recommend we
do and explaining to our people so that
they understand what their rights and
responsibilities are that uh there it's
a voluntary situation there is no
coercion at all uh they and their their
colleagues will will have this pool or
tip sharing whatever the arrangement is
and the employer will merely administer
it uh and all of this explains it very
very well we just don't want you to tell
us to do it because that's a
burden and I I'm really think that if
you have the document and you did
explain it to the employee and they know
everything there is to know before they
begin and they sign that document I
think this gives you some uh lot of a
magic amulet in and against an employee
saying well no I was coerced I didn't
understand what I was getting into I
think this is actually a good thing for
the employer and the employee which is
what I strive for here on the best
Committee in in the legislature the
labor
committee so uh in the other part of the
bill I mean I I do think that people
should know what they're getting into
and understand what happens to their
they don't have they have to share them
with the bartender the hostess the
butcher the baker the Candlestick maker
uh but the other part of the bill that
was concerning to me was that we change
was changed uh service charges are no
longer considered
tips and we were told that the IRS was
taxing the businesses on these service
charges after we got over our shock we
uh we agreed that with that shouldn't
happen and that was not income to the
business but I read this article here um
from Autumn click and Aaron Rosenberg at
sheenny and they kind of said that the
tips are going toward the
employers and that was very unsettling
in fact I reached out to uh Miss click
and I even spoke to uh Jame Rey James
Rey about this it was very concerning to
me and I I think that when you go out to
dinner you're you know not a member of
this labor committee and even we were
taking back back uh and it says service
charge we we think that's for service
that's that's that's like for the for
the people providing the service so I
think it's a little misleading that if
you're presented with something that
says service charges and you think it's
going to the servers uh maybe you're not
going to tip the servers because it's a
service charge and you thought they're
getting it but then they're not getting
it because it goes to the
employer so I think this should be uh I
think the the business the the employ
should be uh transparent with the
customers as well as with the with their
staff and saying well this is a service
charge or an admin fee whatever you want
to call it and it's going for this or it
says that the employer has a choice they
can distribute the service charge as if
it were a tip well they could say well
somewhat of this is going to your server
I think that would be information that
would be uh important for the customer
to know I and I think it the interest of
transparency and fairness uh I think
both start both sections of this uh bill
should be
adopted and there you have it all right
questions go home early you're off the
hook yep thank you
thank
you good afternoon Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record Mike
Summers president CEO of the New
Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association um surprisingly we were
opposed to uh House Bill
757 um certainly appreciate what
representative kahill is trying to do uh
particularly in section uh the first
part of the bill um allowing for uh
business to have in writing what the tip
pooling Arrangement or tip sharing
Arrangement might be I think we're we're
a little bit concerned is that um you
know if it's required to be in writing
and when does that get reviewed how
often can it
change what happens if an employee gets
confused about which version of the
agreement is in place today or next week
so I think there's just some things in
there that we're not really sure exactly
how that would like operate in the real
world
um and then obviously if if uh an
employee does get confused about which
one is in place uh the business then
open to a complaint to the Department of
Labor and then sanctions etc etc
um frankly I think the better solution
for this problem it's not a popular
opinion but I'll share it with you uh
under federal law the business is
allowed to set whatever a tip out policy
might be uh We've advocated for that for
a number of years and this committee has
uh summarily uh disposed of those uh
suggestions but if we were going to make
a change in this section of the statute
I think that's what it should be that
the business owner can set what a tip
out policy should be provided that is
reasonable and customary which is the
federal standard um and if we were to
adopt that I think that would clean up a
lot of the problems that we have uh
within the industry um and then the
service charge language um frankly uh it
is our understanding and I'm interested
to read the article that representative
kill has presented here that a service
charge as far as the IRS is concerned is
considered income of the business and
therefore taxable under federal law and
in that case we feel that that if if
we're going to be paying taxes on it we
should be able to decide how that money
is then distributed and used um now I
will concede that some businesses will
take a portion of that service charge
and will give it to employee employees
so for example if you go to a wedding
and a wedding has a 20% service charge
on the entirety of the event you know
probably 15% of that service charge is
likely being divvied up amongst all the
various people that provided service
during the course of that event that's
just the industry standard so in some
instances that's the case but I think
that should be at the discretion of the
business since we're already paying
taxes on those monies if that makes
sense um and then in in a restaurant
setting I think where we're a little bit
concerned is we now have to break out
how the service charge might be
allocated exactly how is that going to
work and who's going to police it and
then if we don't do it correctly or it's
incorrect to the way we used we handled
the service charge today uh what's the
penalty structure I think there's a lot
of confusion on our part of exactly how
that would be handled um you know who is
going to come in and audit our receipts
uh in a restaurant if we have an
automatic service charge on a party of
eight people who's going to do that how
long do we have to keep the records um
and then you know what's the penalty
structure if if somebody's not in
compliance and how detailed does it need
to be do we need to allocate a
percentage to electricity a percentage
to uh kitchen staff a percentage to
whatever it might be so I think there's
a lot of unknowns in how that is uh is
that is structured so with that I will
end and be happy to try well I guess I
should also add service charges are not
uncommon in the business world I think
everyone just gets excited about the
hospitality industry because you know a
lot of people just assume that maybe it
should be for uh a tip or a gratuiti but
I get service charges for at the car
dealership when I get worked out on my
car I've had uh service charges on my
cell phone bill these service charges
exist as a generic way to just charge
fees for services so uh and I'm I don't
I don't assume that all of those service
charges are then passed through to the
employees I mean it may be in a
roundabout way because it's in wages or
whatever it might be but I again I think
that should be at the discretion of the
employer so with that I will end and I'm
happy to try to answer any questions
represent avalani thank you Mr chairman
thank you again Mr Summers
um for this sections of line 6 through
10 um right now we are supposed to have
employees sign a health certificate for
the food Protection
Services um and we would get dinged if
we didn't have an if we hired we onboard
an employee and forgot to forgot to have
him sign that thing we would get dinged
as well um you also
mentioned if you have if I have a 100
waitresses or 100 weight staff now all
of a sudden I'm missing one am I going
to be subject to fine am I going to be
subject to action by the do because a
different employee complained about it I
would defer to the department on that
but ultimately my suspicion would be
that you would have corrective action 30
days and then penalties would follow
thereafter um but again uh as as many of
you may know and maybe some don't but
you know at the rate which employees
turn over in our industry just keeping
track of this would need a almost a
full-time position just to make sure
everyone had their stuff in their files
I mean it's bad enough now but to just
add another layer to that follow up Mr
chairman follow up U relating to service
charges um a lot of uh businesses are
now passing through credit credit card
fees as a service charge when somebody
uses their credit card correct and I
think that we changed we adjusted the
wording so we wouldn't get dinged on
that and this would bring it back to so
if if you remember uh prior to the
change I think it was in the last
legislative session uh prior to that in
the def definition of a tip it listed
service charge so if you charged a
service charge and it just said service
charge technically it was a gratuiti and
therefore 100% of it had to go to the
employees and businesses would have been
dinged on that um with the change we
made we removed it as part of the
definition so then ultimately because I
think the statute's silent on what a
service charge is I think now it becomes
property the employer and therefore they
can use it as they see fit to pay credit
card fees uh or any other ancillary
costs that have have risen dramatically
over the last few years thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr B any other
questions represent Mackenzie sir thank
you um enforcing labor laws is difficult
and one of the ways that we have been
able to um alert people to what their
rights are is pla cards would you be
opposed to having a plard which details
what what the provisions are under the
pooling so that all ahead of time I
you're you're essentially referring to
all the wage and hour stuff we have to
have posted in our businesses um not
necessarily I mean we have to do that
for a variety of other areas anyway um I
think the issue we would have is that as
rapidly as this committee changes those
rules uh we'd be printing these things
basis fair enough all right uh represent
McKenzie or um G ring sorry thank you Mr
chair so just to confirm I want to
reiterate at this it sounds like you
would be adding to businesses
administrative costs training costs and
several other costs that would be
accured for moving this forward yeah and
primarily because when it comes to wage
and hour the top 10 wage and hour
violations in our industry tip sharing
and pooling and the management thereof
is probably the maybe not number one but
it's way up there on the top of the list
um and this would just add another layer
of complexity to it and I I feel that
that would just be a huge issue
so all right thank you representative K
all right
you and Mr
today thank you last and certainly least
uh John garrian general counsel for the
Department of Labor with me is Deputy
Commissioner Daniel Albert um department
is neutral on the bill uh as Mr Summers
said we we do frequently run into and
enforce and investigate and sight tip
pooling and tip sharing
violations
um uh our our One technical suggestion
on the bill is with the proposed
language um and what we find in our
Enforcement cases is uh the line between
um an
employer um providing notice of an
arrangement or educating staff on an
arrangement um or making suggestions
about an arrangement or what the
employer perceives as making suggestions
about that Arrangement and then what an
employee May perceive as coercion into
that Arrangement that's a very fine line
it can be very it's it's very much a
gray area um our concern is that adding
more kind of twists and turns into that
um process will create more confusion
perhaps more
misconceptions um more perceived
coercion and frankly kind of stickier
situations for us to try to to
unravel um so in terms of the uh service
charge provision um as Mr summer said I
believe two years ago the the term
service charge was removed from the
definition of tip in order to to more to
clarify what was a tip and what is not a
tip um that was in response to several
cases we had where um service charges
were being were being charged and then
not turning into tips and and that
turned into to Major violations so uh
our concern there is that um adding that
term kind of back into the mix in what
might be a tip I think may lead to
confusion though I I will I will say the
this proposed language is a much more
specific definition and has much more
specific rules than the prior use of the
phrase service charge within the
statutes um but with that I'll take any
represent L thank you Mr chairman thank
you Mr garan um line four to include an
example of said practice could you
define that for me as an
employer it is not defined in the bill
and I can't think of a similar
definition that would apply in in the
Department of Labor statutes thank you
follow Mr chairman please um I asked the
Mr Summers the same question as if an
employee was missed on the signing a
written notice would the department be
um uh obviously that would be a
violation and then it would be
corrective action but if it was
concurrent you know there's a lot of
turnover Within These some of these
places and and would it be a you know
one or two names that are missing or
something like that would would there
be you know action of course it it could
be the basis for for a violation I mean
certainly if um we're we're very uh
cognizant of the numbers of the
practices I mean if certainly a a
a restaurant as it were that had no
written receipts whatsoever is in a very
different position kind of an
enforcement sense than restaurant maybe
one or two employees like short-term
employers didn't sign I mean still a
violation but apples and oranges please
would that also open them up to other um
investigations for payroll and whatnot
but given that it is tip
pooling uh it depending on what the the
specific facts of the allegations and
the complaint are it could
yeah it could cause cause an audit to
further records thank you thank you Mr
chairman and represent McKenzie thank
you uh in looking at the language it uh
it would appear that the employee the
burden is on the employee to a certain
extent to know what their rights are and
to um and to act
proactively uh so what I don't
understand is when a restaurant worker
when somebody applies for a restaurant
and they're hired by the restaurant this
law affects them this law they are
covered by this law and tip pooling
correct how is that communicated and
what what how can we document that those
kinds of things have taken place because
as soon as they come through the door
they could be going out that you know
that's all that stuff we're working now
and so I'm I'm worried about that's why
I'm suggested the plet stuff yeah I mean
the the
department to my knowledge doesn't have
any laws requiring notice of this
particular provision uh department does
have laws that require proactive notice
and posters um on other provisions of
the law like pay Equity um uh benefits
um veteran services there's a few more
there no more questions exhausted oh
you've got one more thought you say
we're looking all right go for it thank
you um so the a automatic service charge
would that that fall under your purview
because given that this might be kept as
a tip on the from the employer side or
how would you guys look at that is is if
an automatic service charges for the use
of a credit card compared to an
automatic service charge for a wedding
of a
100 yeah it's an excellent question uh
it's it's a bit of a hypothetical um
because similar I mean this would be
kind of a a novel law a novel situation
um I think ostensibly the department
would be involved if the automatic
service charge um disclosed certain
allocations of that charge that were
then not Faithfully followed or I think
likely in our context if if it said that
you know 75% of the service charge goes
to tips and it turns out 75% of the
charge didn't go to tips but it could
lead to some some enforcement action and
a followup please where would you find
that would it be an an employer policy
whether it be is it is it in statute
somewhere else that that a service judge
needs to be broken down statutorily or
um at just through employment if the
employee says I give 50% of it to my
employees how do you how would you guys
be able to track that uh the only place
it would appear in statute is if this
passed and and this were added to the
law um how would we track it we'd have
to look at business records and records
of the employee or sorry employer to
determine how it was allocated and how
it was paid and
final would that would that open them up
to a larger OB obviously audit it could
yeah I mean depend the audits are very
fact specific it it very it depends very
much on what the facts of the complaint
are what the allegations are we are
limited in our scope under 273 9A um
but often time investigations beget
additional allegations as as we talk to
more to more employees thank you thank
you Mr good good question have cine
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so I I'm hearing a lot about
service charges is there a definition in
Department of Labor that actually
qualifies what a SE or service charge
can be charged or any definition of it
at all not under current law up until a
couple years ago the the term service
charge was within uh the definition of a
tip actually which led to a lot of
confusion because said that a tip can be
a service charge um so not currently
all right well great job thank you for
hanging with us I appreciate your
diligence and your in your input thank
you seeing no further no further pin
cards and no questions I close the
HB
757 uh hey great job today guys um a
long a long day and uh I appreciate your
diligence and and hanging in there and
listening to the great testimony we
heard today so let me just give you a
heads up on next week uh we will meet on
the 18th we'll meet at 10:00 we'll go
through uh the two remaining bills we've
got that that we postponed HP 542
relative to weekly benefit amounts for
unemployment compensation and HB 744
relative to workers compensation
Indemnity benefits and percentage
okay we'll do that from 10: to noonish
as soon as we get out but the idea is to
catch up on amendments and data that
we're supposed to receive from different
folks then at
1300 1 p.m. we will uh exact the rest of
our bills including
744 and 5 and 542 with the intention of
being complete with our slate uh at the
end of next Tuesday is that good with
everyone is a a
o'clock yes ma'am lunch will be at 12
o'clock unless we have a plethora of
over 735 is an exact bill and we will
exact that next week regardless of what
that's correct well introduction and
clear